there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody
it's wednesday oh [ __ ] and uh yeah i was
gonna i was gonna say i just saw it on
the monitor i was like why do you still
have your your earbuds yeah i had
earbuds and i was listening to the damn
music the intro music
and i said i hear you talking and i'm
like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm on the show
yeah i'm on the show he's like trying to
listen to the show yeah he's actually on
the show yeah yeah listening to myself
talk on the show because it's just a
second delay get your [ __ ] together
yeah it's like well yeah i've been on a
couple shows where they had like issues
with that and it's very very
disorienting you hear your own voice
coming back at you like another five
second delay yeah uh you know so it's so
it's that
uh so hey everybody yeah it's wednesday
um hopefully i'll i'll be able to keep
awake pretty sure i only got three hours
of sleep last night so i'm kind of
struggling but um they're all possible
it'll be all right dj maniac says i must
remember not to eat the bay leaves and i
saw that earlier and i was like i'm sure
there's a good story there's a story
about that he must eat eating spaghetti
and eating the bay leaves out of this i
mean technically in the sauce they're
supposed to take the bay leaf out before
they serve it to you yeah although i
will for some reason i don't know why i
remember this but like you know the
shitty like spaghetti lunches they used
to give you like an elementary school in
junior high
somebody always found the [ __ ] bay
leaf in the sauce well there was more
than one but they so they would like
pick it out
but uh yeah you're uh not supposed to
eat that's no big deal okay well no
katie says the stems can perforate your
bowel yeah i could see that oh [ __ ] i
mean anything like that well here's the
thing like my
for example my dad has um diverticulitis
diverticulitis diverticulosis can't rub
roof is one of the other but it's where
you have like these little um like
pockets like in your intestine and you
can't eat anything that has like seeds
on it or
nuts or anything that's like really
small because stuff will get like kind
of stuck in those pockets and it won't
come out and then it causes like
inflammation and you could cause have
like a bowel blow out so he's had to
have like surgeries for it a bunch of
times
so you really have to kind of like um
watch you know what i mean with that
with that kind of stuff especially if
you have that because
well honestly remember we saw that uh
[ __ ] man what was that show we used to
watch i think it was like monsters
inside me or something like that but
maybe it wasn't but then there was like
people that would eat something and then
it had like some tiny ass little [ __ ]
plastic stick in it or something like
that and it poked a [ __ ] hole in
their stomach one was a damn metal
bristle off the damn grill that's right
and that's happened that's the one that
gets you more than once there just
should not be any metal bristles on any
kind of damn
charcoal grill tree cleaning brush yeah
man and i looked in the store every time
i see them in the store now they're all
plastic
yeah they must have made a lot where no
metal yeah because i think that's i mean
that's happened more than once well
because it's not just it's not just a
case of like it perforating your bowel i
think it can also like get stuck in your
throat like perforate your esophagus as
well which is also not a good time just
going there and ripping it up and then
making a hole in the intestines and then
you'd have intestinal [ __ ] juices
going into your abdominal wall you start
digesting yourself
all kinds of bad [ __ ] happens i won't
talk about this though
um we got it was all the bay leaves yeah
it started
it came in [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
y'all [ __ ] i got zardoz
okay so i checked it out
um
this is the blu-ray that they're selling
on on um
on amazon
it's a spanish release
and it is rated it does play it plays
region a b a b c and a b c and i think
abc and i think d or something so i
guess the whole world it plays on
it does have some extras but it's just
uh um
uh pictures of the posters from around
the world
and um
it's weird it's
it's got three different
well
the format is spanish
so all your controls are in spanish
um the the language selection is spanish
dub
spanish dub with spanish subtitles
or the english version with with spanish
subtitles there's no english version
without subtitles i'll try to turn it
off and it there isn't any
so that's the only thing that's
unfortunate about it that's okay i can
learn some spanish yeah
yeah so you can't get the
i always put subtitles i always put the
english subtitles on some deaf as [ __ ]
but you know what i mean the transfer
looks great looks good though
looks good we can watch it later if i
don't fall yeah
um
[Music]
dj maniac said let's talk about bay
leaves my gram ate one by accident when
we were out at a diner once and nearly
choked to death in front of me
yeah cause some of those [ __ ] are big
i could see that happening and then john
gore says i accidentally swallowed a
nicotine lozenge the other day four
milligrams i survived so far
although that's not good man like uh
i've i've heard of like some true crime
cases where people
killed somebody by injecting them with
nicotine or like putting a [ __ ] ton of
wasn't that in a movie where they killed
somebody by putting a bunch of nicotine
patches on it was it thank you for
smoking
where they put like a bunch of nicotine
patches on somebody that actually will
kill you it's like it's funny in the
movie but that actually will kill you
um
tbrigger says uh todd kohlhepp was just
a few counties over from here his
hunting grounds was the area my
girlfriend lives currently going to be
interesting to see and y'all cover him
yeah i want to get to that guy honestly
this was okay
somebody recommended to me the grinder
killer who is a british serial killer
and i hadn't really heard a great deal
about that case and i kind of looked in
and i was like oh that's really
interesting but i said oh let's do like
a whole like a variety show about
different like online killers but the
thing about it is that i didn't really
i was trying to figure out like what the
parameters were because there's a [ __ ]
ton of people that for example
met somebody on a on an internet dating
website or app or something like that
and then ended up killing them but a lot
of them aren't serial killers
so i kind of wanted to pick people
that
either used the internet like primarily
for finding their victims or did some
weird [ __ ] where like they
um like talked about them afterward or
had some kind of like internet component
to their crimes you know what i'm saying
so it was kind of like so i found like
four i don't know if we'll get to all of
them
but because they're not super super long
but
uh somebody mentioned the craigslist
killer i don't think we're gonna go into
that because i'm pretty sure we did that
we talked about the craigslist killer on
another show did we not i don't know i'm
pretty sure we did well at least i
thought we did so that's why i didn't
like want to do it on this one
um
so yeah but uh so i may say i basically
wanted to stick with like serial killers
that had some kind of
internet component whether it was how
they found their victims or
bragging about it afterward or something
like that that was like the parameters i
used dj maniac says the regions are
supposed to be numbers not letters i
don't know where you're getting that man
they're [ __ ] letters we're in region
a
no they usually are uh they usually are
numbers region zero is usually like
every i think region zero everybody can
play it on amazon it's it's number it's
letters
no well no i guess it depends on whoever
the seller is okay but i'm sure like
region zero i think will play anywhere
region one i'm pretty sure is
u.s canada
north america
uh i think region two is europe if i'm
not mistaken i can't really remember i
know it as letters but yeah it is i
guess it's usually numbers i guess we're
in alternate universes
every time i order i order a disk i make
sure it's region a
and that's or or at least region free
i have seen that but
but mostly but mostly it's numbers okay
like like i said that's why i was going
to ask you if you would have got it i
said oh was it region zero because i
think that'll play anywhere
the letters might be european
because
maybe it's european i don't know yeah
because i think it's more an american
thing to have like numbers yeah because
i'm pretty sure it's numbered most of
the [ __ ] but i don't know it's like it's
weird because i mean i guess it's fine
you can buy [ __ ] from other countries
and i know people have
stuff they can play stuff from other
countries and it's not as much of a pain
in the ass it used to be i remember back
in the old days i would buy like i go to
the uk like in the 90s and i'd buy a
movie that you couldn't get over here
like on vhs or whatever and or you know
dvd a little bit later and then i would
have to come back and either have the
vhs transferred um from pal to ntsc or i
would have to buy a player that could
play
all regions of dvds which were not cheap
back then gotta say maniac's saying
we're region one region zero is all done
the bomb jumps in and says region b is
europe and australia so i was right it's
the european system the letters
yeah but i'm just saying that usually
usually i mean i usually i've seen the
num the letters but i usually see
numbers because america's region a
yeah or where either that or maybe it's
maybe maybe region a is everybody i
don't know but i know that region a
plays
yeah so maybe yeah maybe it's a it's a
case of like american sellers like doing
the numbers yeah and then people in
other parts of the world doing the
letters i don't know or just that's the
maybe it's listed in both and that's the
ones i see i look for
yeah maybe
zach says uh i just pirate everything no
problems then
i gotta have factory case or i feel like
i don't have the movie
yeah
i mean i kind of like unless it's
something i don't really particularly
give a [ __ ] about and like i just kind
of want to see it but i don't want to
pay right um
but i mean if i really like something i
will generally spend the money to get
like a good the case and you know yeah
now sometimes if i like something but
not that much um i'll get a used one
like i don't i don't have any aversion
to that but if i really like something i
want to like support the creators
whoever made it or whatever i usually do
try to get it's just like books i very
rarely i buy used books like at a store
but online i like to buy them new like
because i like to support
region a is north america
yeah well yeah we established that yeah
i'm just saying i don't know if it could
be everybody but i didn't know yeah
tyler says i don't pirate mainly because
of viruses yeah i do i you know i kind
of worry about it but
i don't really pirate anything
like i said unless
i have done it before but it was stuff
that i wasn't gonna buy anyways so
it was just something i was kind of
interested in seeing
but you know graham sent me a uh
link to the detroit free press they
found a missing dude
i found a dead guy hanging
hanging from the ceiling why'd you send
this to me graham do we know this guy
kevin bacon
not that kevin b no it's a different
cabin bacon
oh he was put on he's says right here
grinder case in michigan that's what he
said he's talking about like an internet
thing the victim kevin bacon that was
his real name was put on a bdsm
contraption by matt latunsky who slashed
his throat then fried bacon's genitals
in a pan and ate it damn
there's some weirdos out there y'all
i mean i know it's rare but yeah holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] are crazy
yeah how do you get to that place how do
you wake up in the morning
and decide today i'm gonna fry someone's
genitals yeah i'm gonna eat this i'm
gonna eat this dude's dick
i mean some weird [ __ ] i was gonna say
to you that like that's another case
that we've covered before that is kind
of internet related but does that um
what's his name armand muse or whatever
that german dude that yeah that met the
willing
uh
victim like yeah eat like eat me yeah
that's some weird [ __ ] he wanted to be
killed and eaten
that was his fantasy okay
crazy i mean the dude still got in
trouble though because he did still kill
him
even though i think that was his defense
he's like well he wanted to and honestly
i guess he kind of did because like when
he got there like he cut his dick off
and they both ate it and he didn't leave
yeah didn't well didn't he uh didn't he
record it did he record like a statement
that the dude wanted to be eating and
everything yeah he kept everything above
board
although man
i don't know i'm all like uh exploring
your your fun sexual fantasies and
everything but if it involves like
killing another person and eating and
dying and like eating pieces of other
people i wonder if it's wonderful maybe
you need to re-examine your your life
goals
i wonder if it lived up to his
expectations
like i wonder if it turned him on as
much as he thought it was going to i
kind of feel like you know what in
people like that i don't think it ever
does yeah probably went as good as he
thought he was going to well because i
mean and this you can see this in people
that aren't that are normal that aren't
serial killers it's like you always like
the anticipation of something like you
know you build it up in your head it's
going to be super awesome and then when
you do it even if it's cool it's not as
cool as you thought it was gonna imagine
that it was gonna be usually
sometimes it's sometimes life surprises
you and shit's better
but
usually i think the anticipation of
something is always way more fun it's
kind of like you know what it's kind of
like when i was a kid
and
uh you know my grandma she would put up
the christmas tree and she put she'd
wrap all the presents and she would put
all the presents under the tree for all
the kids like a week or two ahead of
time and we were just like dying we were
just like in there like looking at him
and being like what could that one be
look at this but see when you opened um
like the presents were awesome and
everything but it's like i think it was
more fun
to like just look at them and speculate
about what might be in there like i
think the anticipation of it was better
and i think that to a to a large degree
i think serial killers also have that
which is why they tend to like escalate
their [ __ ] because
you know it's like they have all these
fantasies and they're like oh my god now
i'm actually gonna do it and then they
actually do it and they're like that
wasn't quite as awesome as i
was picturing so maybe i just did it
wrong you know what i mean and so well
okay next time we'll be better i'll do
this that and the other thing so i do
kind of feel like there is an escalating
kind of and i think it's and i think
that's why because i think that's a
normal sensation to have
but
uh it's just the most [ __ ] up version
of it imaginable you know
uh tyler says consensual cannibalism is
an entire topic in itself that's some
wild [ __ ] yeah and uh we did do a show
about him like we did a whole show about
arm and muse i think
um
and it's funny because i was watching
i've been watching that true crime show
bizarre murders i don't know what year
it's from it's just i found it on tv
randomly
um that are kind of like
fictionalizations of cases and they did
do a fictionalization of that case they
didn't change a lot of the details just
the names and stuff but
i mean there was enough in there that
you immediately knew exactly what it was
uh didn't he give the cooked penis to
his dog
um yeah i think he did well yeah because
they cooked it because at that point the
victim was still alive it was too tough
and [ __ ] and it wasn't yeah it's like
and it he burned it or it was too tough
and they couldn't really eat it so he's
going to die see again that's kind of
like uh
that's kind of a consequence of like you
imagining what you think it was going to
taste like like a [ __ ] you know jelly
donut or something like that i mean
obviously it's meat and there's not any
fat on it crazy so it's not yeah just
from a practical standpoint it's not
going to taste very good no matter what
you do with it you know what i mean yeah
just just thinking about it
just thinking about that they just want
to beat them dudes up
it doesn't mean you know yeah because
they're [ __ ] crazy what would they
need their ass
they need their asses they probably like
it though yeah
what's that once somebody has like gone
over a certain line i don't know if
there's anything
sorry guys y'all are [ __ ] crazy
you're making me making me mad you're
making me mad all this eating this
dude's dick and him you in this i'm
gonna have to beat y'all's ass
let's start beating him up
you guys you guys need your asses beat
think about this
john gore says speaking of cannibalism i
just watched bone tomahawk great
that is a fantastic movie yeah matter of
fact i was talking to uh my friend from
military academy he worked on that movie
i mean that i mean the scene at the end
is one of the most brutal [ __ ] yeah
uh
if it's not really evisceration they
just like cut a dude in half like from
the crotch
crotch first matter of fact before just
right before you mentioned that before
the the the show started it is brian
brian hackett we grew up together i
haven't seen him forever we just talked
online we were at military school
together
and
brian was talking about that last case
that we did from beverly the director
from was it the director from beverly
hills cop three
that was uh what's his name's brother
teddy's got yeah tony scott it was that
was ridley scott's brother
he jumped he didn't jump off a building
somebody it was the bridge this is the
bridge it was the vincent thomas bridge
yeah that's right which is a big old
[ __ ] suspension bridge at least at
least i think that's the vince of thomas
because i remember being kind of blue
but grayish blue bridge that went over
the sea over there near damn the uh
[ __ ]
queen mary in the spruce goose it's over
in that area that's where i remember but
i haven't been here since i was kid he
jumped off that bridge
i was asking why he jumped he hasn't
answered yet
he listens to all the shows recorded i
don't think anybody knows i mean from
what i could determine i don't know a
great deal about it but i think his
family's like kept it pretty he did
leave a note yeah um but i don't think
his family is like releasing like what
it said because it's nobody's business
but brian's friends with crustal got
like he sent me a lot of pictures of him
in crustal
um he uh did some stuff on that last uh
uh crossover movie uh where we played
snake prince pliskin you know like
escape from la he was in that one
um then brian
brian worked on uh bone tomahawk and he
worked on uh vfw which is a [ __ ]
great movie and i loved him yeah that
was really good yeah and he just got
done with that uh
making that movie with um
um it's called terror on on a prairie
and that was called terror on the
prairie
yeah i think with um what's her name
girl who play cara dune on um
she's decorating what's that janet
carano yeah gina carano yeah he just did
her movie
jenny remembers all the names say i got
a head injury i don't remember people's
names that well
i forget jenny's name okay so
i tease him
he doesn't remember [ __ ] i don't
remember his names and i don't remember
and i had numbers picture of everything
and i remember everything that we said
and everything we talked about it's just
i have a problem with labeling things i
remember well i don't remember
everything my memory's not as good as it
used to be because i'm getting older but
um i mean i used to be able to just like
pull [ __ ] out by like i don't even i
don't even know how i know things yeah i
told you dude i used to watch jeopardy
yeah and they would ask questions and
i'd answer it and i'd be like how the
[ __ ] do i know that i don't know i read
it somewhere and it just like lodged
itself in my brain and what's weird is
that from my childhood i will remember
some [ __ ] bizarre [ __ ] and [ __ ]
details and everything from childhood
well older people that the older they
get um the more like vivid their their
memories from childhood are but the less
they can remember like all the [ __ ]
though
yesterday yeah right because it gets
harder to like make new memories that's
why it's probably what it is you're
right your brain gets flabby that's why
you're [ __ ] built not you're not
built to last okay when you eventually
get so old you're like ah [ __ ] it i'm
gonna die i don't give a [ __ ] it's only
a few years from now anyway
grantham says b12 vitamins help with
early memory loss [ __ ] i can get that
i mean they can get those everywhere i
can get well no i was thinking about the
injectable versions i can get injectable
versions i'll inject that [ __ ] i've
heard that uh
uh if you really want the benefit of
vitamins inject them you don't need them
but i have to see what the doses are now
that i can just inject myself with
anything you know i don't give a [ __ ]
you know
how to look into some of those
injectable vitamins
because it doesn't go through the
[ __ ] doesn't go through your [ __ ]
right digestive system yeah i mean you
know uh
technically you would think that it was
going right into your bloodstream
instead of having to like seep out into
your bloodstream yeah well what's
here's a weird thing people before we
get onto this program you say well
vitamins don't do much
back in the early days of [ __ ]
bodybuilding they
vitamins
actually is what they gave the cattle
they were injecting
vitamins into cattle and they were
getting bigger
they were injected bodybuilders were
injected into themselves too and they
claimed to have gotten bigger and there
was a time where they were doing
steroids early steroids and vitamins
side by side in different dudes
and they claimed the results
were a little bit better for the
vitamins but then they had evidently
started to like really up the dosages on
the damn steroids and the guys of the
steroids got bigger and then even the
[ __ ] cattle industry went to steroids
over vitamins but there was a time
where
vitamins were considered to be more
powerful than steroids if they were
injected
and it made a lot of sense when somebody
told me that story was like oh well
that's why it bugs bunny and the old
bugs bunny cartoons was injected himself
with vitamins
yeah remember this remember when that
happened
bugs bunny injected him as a scene where
bugs bunny injects himself with vitamins
he gets huge and fights somebody
and it didn't make any damn sense really
when you think about it but yeah because
i was like is that heroin or yeah what
is it
but you know but it makes sense that's
what i was thinking it makes sense it
makes sense when you looked at it from
the point of view of
pre-steroids and and uh pre you know in
the in the cattle industry that yeah
they were i didn't realize that they
were injecting those cattle [ __ ]
steroids and i think it was b12
i think it was b vitamin
tb trigger says if you had to have a
body part amputated and have the chance
to keep it would you eat it no
no but i but the thought would cross my
mind though i thought it would cross my
mind you know how i am i'm crazy i'm a
horror person that's crazy i wouldn't do
it but i would think about it for says
like i wonder what it tastes like
i would think about it uh somebody said
i'll tell you some weird [ __ ] that i saw
though and i saw some weird [ __ ] one
time i was going down in the mailboxes
at the old house
i was walking back to the [ __ ] house
up the driveway
and saw a big lizard
chased down a little lizard and beat it
up real quick bit it and started shaking
it the little lizard was only about that
big the big lizard was about that big
and when he did that the tail of that
little lizard fell off and then the big
lizard ate that tail right away
well yeah lizards are uh cannibalistic
yeah i didn't realize that yeah so i
guess dropping your tail is a way
for a little bit
it's a defense mechanism yeah well yeah
a lot of lizards have that not just not
just those little bitty ones that we
have here in florida um a lot of lizards
that's why the tail comes off it's a
bonus life it's a bonus life yeah
because if somebody because generally
like evolution yeah uh you know they get
grabbed by the tail because it's long
and it's sticking out there so the ones
whose tail is detached and then it kind
of grew back
he didn't grab him by the tail though i
saw it he grabbed it by the midriff the
belly and was shaking it yeah and the
tail went flying yeah and he threw the
[ __ ] lizard away and went for the
tail yeah like he knew that that he
could get a free tail
yeah they probably do know that yeah
because like i said a lot of people a
lot of lizards their their tails come
off yeah they'll grow back that i don't
think they grow back quite as
cool like sometimes they're a little
stumpy but they do like they do grow
back i was blown away he know how to get
a free meal out of beating up a little
one
he's like he's like the bully where's
your lunch money yeah give it a bunch of
money
that's what that is
dj mini x uh tells tv drinkers who were
just talking if uh if you had your leg
cut off would you eat it uh there's a
great story on the risk podcast about
the guy who made a taco out of his
amputated leg and served it to his
friends
that is kind of funny i mean it's your
leg yeah so i mean if you can find
enough friends it's like hey wanna see
what my leg tastes like it might have
been good i don't know danny rowling
says uh just saw the film vampires kiss
starring your boy nicholas cage that was
a funny thrill ride of a film i've been
wanting to do vampires kiss on the
[ __ ] matinee or the movie
retrospective for such a long time it
never wins in the poll though so we
might have to do it on uh that movie is
[ __ ]
something else
[Laughter]
nicholas cage is like uh cajun the [ __ ]
out in that movie big time it's
hilarious
um
lord haiti says in a scientific study if
you're going to eat a person the brain
is actually recommended yeah i can see
that
yeah making a taco out of your feet i'm
sorry i just thought of that like
stephen king story survivor type where
he eat himself piece by piece well okay
the island
if i lost a leg and i was like
if there's like an airplane accident you
lose a leg
and uh you know there's no food around
do you eat the leg in a situation like
that yeah you do but let's go to the
damn doctor and they amputate the leg no
you don't eat that [ __ ] they're taking
it off because something's wrong with it
anyway it's probably not gonna be any
good meat not gonna be good meat anyway
it would be neat if you could keep it
though
although if you wanted to keep it you'd
have to like take it to one of those
remember like when a few years ago they
did that bodies exhibition where they
had that like uh that stuff they
injected into like actual corpses that
turned it into like plasticine or
something yeah um i saw that in tampa
that was amazing
holy [ __ ] that was cool well in that
james bond movie casino royale
james bond goes down to miami and that
that exhibit was on what was up remember
he knifes that guy yeah in the middle of
that i saw that that uh exhibition i
have the but i have the museum like from
james bond comes to florida james bond's
always in florida well now it's it
toured around it was all over the world
i saw it when it was in tampa i was just
saying james bond was in florida that's
all i'm saying oh okay
yeah i think it's been in florida
several times in the movies probably
yeah because florida is seen as like
well i don't know it was exactly i don't
know about nowadays but people like it's
like an exotic vacation
destination it is
it's like come down here and a crackhead
will eat your face off no or you'll get
eaten by an alligator
she's full of [ __ ] no i'm just saying
that's how people perceive it nowadays
that's how people perceive it
back in the old days it was either oh
everything's beach and spring break or
it's everything is old people yeah and
it was never really either one of those
no i mean that was a significant portion
but it was like little i mean you know
it's just like any other state there's
like [ __ ] people from everywhere here
the most i think the most uh realistic
depiction of florida that i've seen in
an old movie would have been
from um
uh the movie uh the island remember when
[ __ ] michael caine goes down to goes
down to miami yeah and then goes they
show
orlando when they're driving
and the second
another good depiction would be a pain
and gain with the rock that's that's
very miami that movie was very miami
but like i said it's just like any other
place probably in florida it depends on
what part of florida you're talking
about what you're doing for a living
i mean florida to me seems like it's in
at least like three or four different
zones yeah you know there's four or
fives if they're four or five i mean at
least three or four yeah probably the
panhandle is very different the panel
the panhandle is mississippi that's kind
of like what people think of when they
think of like florida crackers or like
really like hick redneck hillbilly stuff
yeah it's like that in the panhandle
yeah
but um central florida is nothing like
that and south florida is absolutely
nothing like that
so you know what i mean central florida
where i where we are right now
and you know
actually being born in california and
living there until like the very early
80s
the orlando area and right outside
orlando reminds me a lot of vista
california
and san diego area
back in the 70s and the very early 80s
it has that kind of feel to it
it doesn't look like that
a lot of way it's a lot newer but it
it has that feeling it's that same kind
of place where it's like on the edge of
the city at least that's the way it was
back in the 70s and uh
vista and san diego it's like that
but uh yes people are just still talking
about uh cannibalism talk about eating
the brain and yeah one thing that i was
like thinking of is uh probably not a
good idea to eat human brains because
you're gonna get
what they call in some countries kuru or
what they call mad cow disease because
they give the cows mad cow disease
because they're eating other cows like
in their feed um you get that from like
eating
your own species obviously not all
species have that because a lot of
species are cannibalistic but um i would
be afraid of like eating human brains
even if i had yeah you never eat that
because uh yeah you probably get like a
bad cow or a bad person whatever you
don't wanna this is just just in general
okay this is you know coming from a
family
that's very much into wild game and deer
and fish and [ __ ] don't eat sweet meats
don't meat eat internal organs it's too
risky
just eat
regular lean meat i i was i wasn't going
to anyways yeah don't eat any of that
there's too many things that can go
wrong with internal organs with the
exception of the heart the hardest
muscle
that's safe to eat
but even liver and kidney is dangerous
to eat unless you really know what
you're doing it's not worth it
especially not on a deer
yeah
you know what they're small they
wouldn't taste good anyway that's eating
very low on the hog if you have access
to the supply of venison you want the
choice cuts you don't want
that's what i mean it's like if you have
access to like actual meat why would you
want to eat like they don't really taste
all that good no to me i mean i'm sure
that like some people have a taste for
them but beef liver can be good it went
done right but it has that liver flavor
that's what you're looking for
yeah some people like that really some
people like my grandmother loved that
[ __ ] yeah she looks like easter i i
developed it too she had brains too yeah
i developed a taste for for fried liver
in the army because they did offer that
the army would get their hands on it but
no man
that does not compare to say [ __ ]
pork tenderloin or flaming yawn or
good [ __ ] roast you know you're crazy
no that's that's where the good chips
yeah i don't really want to eat back in
the honky motherland only rich people
could eat that in the medieval era okay
only the lord ate that everybody else
had to eat like everybody else eat that
crappy [ __ ]
right
here have to stout yeah
eat a tongue
although tong's tongue is good
especially beef tongue beef tongue is
great
honestly i kind of feel like tongue has
made a resurgence yeah because i've seen
it like in some kind of high-end
restaurant menus and [ __ ] like in
brazilian when i was in brazil they knew
how to you go to hospital and they
[ __ ]
a beautiful tongue they slice it real
thin and everything and it's just
kind of like a
slice a real thin slice of roast beef
kind of like that good real good
lord haiti says all of you are going to
hate me but i have never seen a james
bond movie
oh man watch to watch the um casino
royale and um quantum of solace uh the
daniel craig james bond i can vouch for
a lot of the other ones are kind of
goofy
you know they had some good ones
they also had
some bad ones um
i wasn't big into roger moore
although he had a few good ones it's
just that roger moore ran for a long
time and he wasn't real credible i mean
he's a little bit of a cheese dick kind
of a cheesy [ __ ] he was
an older guy
an older guy yeah he's a good looking
guy but
19 year old supermodels are not
interested in
guys pushing 60. yeah they were a little
creepy about that kind of [ __ ] look look
i know it's james bond and he's supposed
to be all slick and like ladies man and
[ __ ] but it's like
uh sir
that girl is young enough to be your
daughter right can we just like
right let's please desist
if you go back to the ian fleming novels
i'd say that
the daniel craig movies were closer
to to the ian fleming's description of
who james bond was he was kind of beat
up looking at
and drank a lot and they usually had to
pull his ass out of the gutter before a
mission
um
which is kind of more realistic to like
how a real person that did that for a
living would be you'd have like a lot of
coping mechanisms yeah i'm just saying
yeah well he was kind of soldierly you
know and
a lot of physicality in him
uh he beat up kind of looking in his
face and
the newer ones i think did a pretty good
job now the very last one
a lot of people didn't like it but i
liked it because it was an homage
and they were uh sending the daniel
craig off into the sunset and they did
this they homaged all the old james bond
movies including some of the cheese from
from i appreciated that lives yeah i see
what you're doing yeah they they they
did some cheese from the front front
from
from the old james bond movies in there
too
uh because we knew that was going to be
the last one with daniel craig in it
um
they're gonna pick a new bond
and i don't know why they didn't [ __ ]
um pick my boy but
well
we're not gonna know who james bond is
but by rights it should be i mean
they're gonna put out all kind of that's
what they do nowadays because they want
everybody to be like surprised right
because everybody knows everything about
everything because of the internet so
they always try to put out like [ __ ]
you know
weird rumors and weird stories and [ __ ]
like that so everybody's like doesn't
know what's going on exactly
if you ask me the the next james bond
should be the guy who played mad max
what's his name [ __ ] um tom hardy tom
hardy he would be a good james bond tom
hardy would be a is but he's been in so
many [ __ ] movies
but he's [ __ ]
gutting for that role
but i think he was born for that role
yeah i think he'd be rad actually yeah
that's
that's who they're talking about jason
says henry cavill he would yeah he'd
probably be pretty good which one
i haven't seen a [ __ ] ton of stuff with
him in it but yeah he'd probably be good
too which guy is that um he was in i
don't know if you've seen anything what
the [ __ ] wasn't he in [ __ ] passion of
the christ i feel like i didn't see that
one
tom hardy really would be
james bond that's who they're talking
about i don't know if he's a little too
old now how old is tom is tom hardy
james for um you want bond you want him
in his first movie to start off in his
30s
yeah he's got to be like a little bit
yeah so he's like pretty sure but like
not an old fart that's like running
after like hot young right and he's not
a kid right he wanted to be 38
yeah somewhere around there right
that seems like a good idea you want to
be able to get four or five movies out
of him
you want to get four or five movies out
of him
james bond could be in his 50s
uh in his final movies
but he's got to be [ __ ] physical he's
got to be [ __ ] yeah that's the thing
i think a lot of actors they're like
look we're gonna need a contract for at
least like three four five movies and
it's like you have to stay in like
[ __ ] good shape right like the whole
time we're making those movies because
you know right they do a lot of their
own stunts well hardy would do that
though hardy's not afraid of doing roids
he's not already he trains i've seen
videos of tom hardy and that
[ __ ] was training and he was
very intense yeah yeah but in a good way
yeah yeah i know he's he's taking it
seriously yeah he was great in bronson
uh he was great in everything that i saw
him and venom the two venom movies i
thought they were fantastic and he
helped produce those
yeah and i you know i liked him and i
mean everybody knows how much we love
fury road he was great yeah and
fury rose he was great in um
oh [ __ ] what was that other one he was
in that [ __ ] i [ __ ] loved it oh
and venom when he played not venom uh in
batman when he played uh
um
what was the name of that [ __ ] bane
memory played
batman he did a great job
so i think he'd be a great bond and he
said no not him he's too well known and
i'm like what the [ __ ] you do talking so
is daniel craig though yeah so his dad
what the [ __ ]
i mean at least i thought he was
well-known i put tom hardy because he
fits it he's a white british guy and
that's exactly and he's got that [ __ ]
look and he's got that attitude that
because that's kind of like daniel craig
was kind of like that so he would just
you know well and daniel craig also
started out in british crime films right
uh you should probably see you know what
you should see layer cake
okay you might like that movie actually
remember when hardy did the [ __ ] with
the reggie and ronnie cray rolls yeah
that was [ __ ] great what was the name
of that [ __ ] somebody sent us that
movie that was great movie crime movie
yeah they made man they've made so many
movies about the craze yeah they made
one just just called the craze yeah
which had uh the dude from spandau was
he from spandau ballet or it was the
brother of the dude from spanish valley
i can't remember now that was a while
back that was like in the 80s um yeah so
i wanted to say uh it says tom hardy's
about 43 i think that's that's that's
okay 43 is young enough
with his level of physicality he could
he could be
he could be in a first james bond movie
underneath under okay look there's one
dude that was [ __ ]
close to to uh to daniel craig and that
was um
uh the dude who uh from living uh what
was the move they did living daylights
and uh
here's timothy dalton timothy dale
timothy dalton did a pretty good but i
haven't seen his movies in a long time
he did two james bond movies i saw the
first one in the theater as a kid and i
was blown away
living daylights and they had aha did
the [ __ ] theme song for you i know
every time you say the title i think of
the yeah and it was it was real hardcore
for the time
i was like oh this is unlike any james
bond that i'd seen it was like real
gritty but i want to go back and see
that one i'm gonna buy that one
maybe my memory may be wrong of it
but i remember we saw malone last night
with [ __ ]
burt reynolds
it was it was good it was good it was
it's uh i think it's on free in it for
amazon prime
yeah
he played the cia assassin who was
trying to get out of the damn business
well we can talk about it on sunday
we'll talk about it on sunday it's
pretty good hello don't blow the don't
blow the load
no i just wanted to say because i got
really behind on the comments um our
friend david parker is here okay yeah uh
hey what's up you're not you're not
going to mannequins tonight i kind of
feel like you're always yeah because
he's usually it's wednesday oh that's
right i can't we're doing the show so
for some reason i think it's friday but
that's right it's wednesday that's
what's going on at mannequins tonight
but karaoke probably and i think it's
karaoke at once yes actually we went to
karaoke one time and it was i think
there was like five people there and it
was it was fun though zack's talking
about no time to die it made him cry i
like no time to cry i i haven't bought
it though i gotta buy it on on blue on
blu-ray but uh you you liked it zach i
liked it i thought it was good
they did they did a lot of homages the
talking eye the eyeball thing the i
thought that was a trip you had the girl
who was the bond girl with the [ __ ]
machine guns
she did her little thing the girl that
from blade runner you know they had a
lot of good
shout outs to the old james bonds in it
and then [ __ ] felix died they wrapped
his [ __ ] story up
and uh yeah
because that felix character was a
[ __ ] good character in in this in
this one i don't know is that you think
you think tom hardy be a good [ __ ]
bond i think he'd be great was that
thunder yeah okay
[ __ ] we had like a really bad storm last
night like it kept me awake until like 3
30 in the morning yeah so uh that's why
i'm so [ __ ] tired uh yeah oh david
says he uh he is at mannequins it's
karaoke night oh he is or he's gonna he
or he is gonna go it's karaoke
yeah we went one time like a long time
ago because we were like boarding home
and said let's see what's going on it
was actually kind of fun it was fun
there wasn't a lot of people there but
um yeah it was like pretty fun
uh but yeah somebody uh
oh road to perdition you know what i
keep meaning to like watch that movie
and i still haven't seen it and david
says oh i got my 13 o'clock shirt
yesterday
too awesome
thanks very much yeah thanks for getting
that yeah from the zazzle store zazzle
yeah yeah because we haven't looked god
we really need to get in like making
those [ __ ] ones again i just
i've just been so busy and i haven't
gotten around to like yeah making new
ones john smith
said fleming's novels were pretty weird
though he's they said things like
homosexuals can't whistle
oh you must have been joking did it no
they there was some weird [ __ ] like back
then i never heard that one although
you've heard the one about how like
asian girls had like sideways yeah that
was always [ __ ] that was always that
was a joke
people didn't believe that
i don't think people believe that
probably some people did i don't think
only an idiot would believe that
yeah but there's lots of idiots in the
world that's what i'm saying
um all right so
we've been going almost an hour should
we should we actually start uh no to
talk a little bit i'm gonna go to the
restroom and then we'll come back and
start oh okay yeah hold on
man i'm almost well i'm not really
almost to the bottom of the drink it's
like just talking about his young wife
and what a creeper he was
he was 34 and she was 21. that's not
creeper dude i mean people get sensitive
over that [ __ ] it just happens
yeah she's legal yeah
i just like 34 and 21 that's like not
really i'm kind of thinking
because that's not like young enough to
be your daughter i'm kind of thinking
like young enough to be your daughter
that's when it starts getting creepy
everybody seems to think that tom hardy
be a good bond i think it'd be a great
bond
but uh and tammy says that too
i just cannot believe i mean i've
watched tom hardy in anything yeah i
just can't believe that [ __ ] um oh
what's her name broccoli said no to tom
hardy that's the that's the word
that either that or that's what they're
putting out there they're like just
kidding it had actually because uh
miss broccoli runs the [ __ ]
and evidently she said no
yeah because cubby broccoli was the
producer like until he died wait a
minute hold on you got a star who is
just [ __ ] born
for that role with that [ __ ] with his
film with his [ __ ] films behind him
and all the good [ __ ] that he did doing
the craze and doing bronson and all
these [ __ ]
and this dude is
[ __ ] james bond that's that's who
that book those books are talking about
and you say no to him now
i don't understand that maybe he's
already got a box office draw people
would see the [ __ ] out of that movie
well that's what i'm saying
says i go by the old thing of don't go
any younger than half your current age
plus seven
yeah i could see that like i said the
older you get like the less weird it is
really i'm just weirded out if it's like
a much younger
person with like a a person that's old
enough to be their parent you know what
i mean like if it's
10 years different something like that i
mean that's what my um
my grandparents like my grandfather was
10 years older than my grandmother and i
never thought that was particularly
weird um because you know he was
obviously like older he was out of the
military and then she was like 18 or 19
when they got married so it wasn't
really all that weird i'm just kind of
like so if it's 10 years 12 years
something like that it's not that weird
when you're getting into a thing where
it's like this
person is like young enough to be my kid
like
and i wasn't a teen mom then yeah that's
a little weird that would be like me
dating
like a 30 year old you know what i'm
saying
that would be weird i think i don't want
to date any 30 year olds but i'm just
saying that that i would think that was
weird so it's it goes both ways it's not
just old man young woman i think it's
weird the other way too
everybody would think it was weird if i
was dating a 30 year old i kind of feel
like i would think it was weird i don't
know if other people think it was weird
um all right so let me see
grantham says in thailand you see 80
year old white dudes with 18 year old
thai girls everywhere yeah i you know
like i get it if
there's other like transactions involved
and like the girls are just kind of like
well this is like an old [ __ ] and maybe
he's rich and
if he kicks off maybe i'll get his money
you know i could see that but
you know
john goris says the broccoli seem to
like finding relative unknowns and
trademark them as bond which i guess you
know that's fair enough um they want
somebody that's not recognizable as
another character
like to so it's more
you know immersive i suppose like i get
that that's not a you know that's not a
stupid thing to think
but i'd still i do think tom hardy would
be a good one
um
did daniel craig play james bond yes he
did
uh lord hades who
uh has not seen any of the bond movies
he was the most recent bond um he
recently just uh he did five it was five
movies right
it was five movies right the daniel
craig yeah i wouldn't uh quantum of salt
casino royale quantum of solace
uh [ __ ] um skyfall skyfall
no time to die
i wouldn't do it in this day and age not
with the way the box offices are you
need a [ __ ] hit you need a star
a star that could carry that role and he
was born for that i'd put tom hardy in
that [ __ ]
because he's already got a huge fan base
yeah i just i just would
yeah
mango is saying uh henry cavill should
be bond yeah i get i mean i get that
because he does have that look and who
he is he's not as i mean he's kind of
well known but i don't think he's as
well known as tom hardy is so i don't
know i could maybe see him going and
that like i said i haven't seen henry
cavill in a lot of things so
what who did he play what movie did we
talk about well like i said i've only
seen him in a couple of things and i
can't remember them like right now but
yeah i know who i know what he looks
like i can picture him but
you might not have seen him in anything
from what i remember
bond was not some big tall good-looking
dude this that was a that's a that was
something about the movies were like
that
he was supposed to be a short boxer
looking kind of guy he was always beat
up and [ __ ] drunk and all [ __ ] up
when he wasn't working and they had to
clean him up to go do this [ __ ] he
wasn't kind of
he wasn't
this [ __ ] kind of
invincible [ __ ] superhero type guy
oh that's right he was in some of the
new superman movies wasn't he henry
cavill that's right he's the guy that
played superman he played superman and
some of the newer ones yeah
i wouldn't do that dude i forgot i
didn't see her i didn't see those that's
a tom hardy in there
and he was in mission impossible fallout
says tyler i remember seeing fallout
fallout was good and the witcher which i
haven't seen
but i know everybody was talking about
the witcher though so i will get around
to it but i'm trying to yeah i got to
see the fallout again
we saw the theater didn't we yeah i
don't think that was the last mission
impossible was it
i think there's another one after that
winner
not let's see it okay i don't know
i don't know
he was superman okay i know you're
talking about yeah yeah he was here for
me
i don't know
i mean we'll see you like i said you're
saying well he already played a spy and
all that's irrelevant because people
didn't see those movies more probably
well i mean just because you didn't see
him doesn't mean other people didn't see
them you know yeah but tom hardy made a
lot of movies because some of the ones
they're bringing up like you know tom
hardy made a lot of movies but this is
the modern era
in the modern era they put these movies
out and they're [ __ ] great and nobody
sees them
it's just you know what i mean it's just
like marketing is not the same it's not
there's just so there's so much
competition well like i said there's
[ __ ] out there that like i by all right
should have seen by now and i just
haven't got around to it because i just
haven't had time
some of my favorite movies
that are recent
you guys are probably like i haven't
seen that movie [ __ ] and and and the
average person would be like that [ __ ]
suck like i [ __ ] really love [ __ ]
uh vivarium and [ __ ]
self-defense i also loved whoever yeah
now what's that dude his name [ __ ]
jesse heisenberg yeah which people would
let some people might laugh at that
dudes but
i'm like nah that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] great at choosing product pro
choosing projects that had
really good artistic qualities to them
they're really unique movies
of self-defense man [ __ ] that
director just
you would think that i wouldn't like a
movie like that i know i [ __ ] love
there's a certain amount of truth now
that movie was true that movie was very
true
but truth depends upon a certain point
of view and that guy's showing me a
different point of view of what he's
taught and it was just a great movie
and bavarian was the same way you know
it was just this weird sci-fi movie
about a damn extra-dimensional damn
parasite that made you raise its child
just weird as [ __ ]
and he picked those movies and he had
that same
woman with him as a co-star in both of
those movies imogen hoots imogen yeah
she's great too i don't know if there's
some kind of relationship there if
they're just friends or i don't think so
i think they just like work together a
lot i don't know i don't keep up with
that stuff so and i think those movies
kind of came and went nobody noticed
them but those were masterpieces
masterpieces
well like i said and i've said this
before anybody ar you know actors
whatever artists whatever um if they're
willing to
choose projects that they know aren't
necessarily gonna make any money but
they that they are passionate about and
they're really like i respect that a lot
more than just taking [ __ ] for a
paycheck although if you do take [ __ ]
because look everybody's got to eat i
get that if you do take [ __ ] for a
paycheck at least don't phone it in
yeah like look at nicolas cage he'll
take he'll take anything he'll be in
anything yeah but he always does this is
that his cages yeah right yeah which
like i said i respect that too it's a
different strategy
but that is also cool
but eisenberg and that image and check i
want to see more of their movies i don't
know what they're working on now i got
to go see if he's got anything new uh
just on the back of those two movies
right there i respect his judgment about
what kind of pro what kind of project to
be in
and i know he did some comedic kind of
crazy [ __ ] but
no [ __ ] he's serious man that's some
serious [ __ ] those two movies
yeah lord haiti says i know craig from
knives out i mean knives out was a great
movie yeah but that was a completely
different character right then uh yeah
no you want to see bond the the bond
move but that just kind of goes to show
his range because he actually did play
like a completely different character
what's that director's name again
[ __ ] it did knives out
he did uh ryan johnson brian johnson
yeah but he [ __ ] star wars up but he
was great his that knives that was great
i don't believe i don't i don't agree
with his star wars action
but
knives out he was great [ __ ] that's
that's
that was a good movie for him i'm not
for him that's
i'm just saying he is a good director
he's a good director i just don't
there's just certain people well i kind
of feel like big ips that wasn't really
what he wanted to do but it's kind of
like when they asked for duties like
okay i'll make all the money so that's
fine i mean i would have done it too you
wouldn't have turned it off just that's
not his strength you need somebody who's
real concerned he liked i mean when he
did knives out you could i mean that
movie was awesome yeah you can see
that's what he want to do he want to do
like an old school murder mission yeah
yeah he's great at that yeah
there's a uh the thing with star wars in
the star wars world is that you have to
have [ __ ]
uh real kind of true believer type
directors who are real conservative in
terms of where they're gonna go it has
to be within the star wars narrow
bandwidth yeah because that's what
that's what the customers want
uh you can't get real artistic with that
and you have to it's all lore based
nerdy [ __ ]
just like
tolkien you can't [ __ ] with [ __ ]
tolkien it has to be a certain time the
nerds will revolt they will ner it's a
nerd the [ __ ] out yeah
all right can i finally get to the case
let's get to the [ __ ] let's get to the
let's get the show i have like four
cases dude so [ __ ] i told you this i
told you this before we started it's
okay well hey it was a 15-minute intro
that's normal
about 15 minutes uh an hour it was an
hour oh yeah um jim from jim varney yeah
yeah james bond all right so uh tonight
we're talking about you know occasion
now we're talking about
internet homicide as wikipedia calls it
now
there is some okay and i get this there
is some kind of like controversy in law
enforcement in people that study these
kinds of things criminology
if this even should be
its own category because i kind of feel
like there is a category for
internet killers or people who primarily
stalk their victims online you know what
i mean like you know finding them
through like dating apps or whatever or
through craigslist or whatever like the
craigslist killer and uh some law
enforcement or some kind of like
criminology type people are kind of like
well
um is this really a thing though because
the internet is so ubiquitous in
everyone's lives that it's really not
the internet's fault it's not really
facilitating
that to a degree that you can like call
it a separate category you know what i'm
saying um
but i would argue because okay because
some people have argued well look if i
called you up
like from an ad that you ran in a
newspaper and asked you out on a date
and then i murdered you would that be
like a telephone crime like i get that
um but i will say too that
murderers back in the old days when they
used to have uh classified ads you know
what i mean we've done a couple of cases
like that where i think belgiumis did
that kind of [ __ ] too where back in the
old days you'd run like a personal ad
being like hey i'm a woman with this
many acres and this many cows and
looking for a husband and i got this
much money blah blah blah and then they
would come out there to you know see her
and then she would like whack him the
head and bury him in the [ __ ] garden
you know what i mean um
so you could argue that it wasn't
obviously the newspaper's fault that
that happened she was just using the
technology available to her at the time
to
draw victims to her
but on the other hand uh that is
something that
because i kind of feel like when
people kill people
like back in the old days when they had
classified ads when they used to kill
people
from classified ads they would always
call them like a lonely hearts killer so
they did actually like acknowledge
um
that that was like a component of the
crimes rather than just
stalking through the street or you know
whatever like finding victims like
through [ __ ]
friends or just like driving by or
whatever
so
while the internet is just so much a
part of everyday life now that i don't
really think that it merits
necessarily a different category
um i can see why they do
kind of uh
why it's kind of like a quick um sort of
thing to call the people
when they go most of their victims like
they found through the internet you know
what i'm saying so it's kind of like i
don't know i i get why there's a
controversy about it so i wanted to
mention this briefly because this case
here it's not i don't even know if it's
a case because this kind of went around
back in i think it was 2015
and as far as i know uh no one is
actually sure if this is actually really
a serial killer that is actually like
you know out there operating or if it's
some kind of like weird elaborate hoax
or some other kind of [ __ ]
so back in 2015
some dude starts posting on 4chan
and he says that he's starting a game
with the people i got it that um that
are present
he says i'm gonna post a picture of a
woman
and if one of you can guess her name in
the next like however much time then i
will tell you where her body is buried
so he starts doing that and like some
people thought he was just like
faking or whatever but some people were
like okay whatever and they just started
like guessing names and i guess one of
the people got the name right
so then he puts up another picture
of what appeared to be the same woman
from the photo where she was you know it
was just like a regular
like studio photo of her when she was
alive uh and then posted another photo
of her where it looked like the same
person like dead
and so this person
like posted a whole bunch of times and i
saw it i don't think it's on 4chan
anymore i think this
of all the things like 4chan will won't
kick off anybody but i think it kicked
off this dude
um so they took it off but obviously
somebody saved it so it did get like
archived so i was actually able to find
it on another site i can't remember what
it was murder killer or something like
that but you can find it if you like
look for 4chan serial killer
it's like one of the like the third or
fourth thing that comes up and it has
all the photos that were originally
posted because somebody archived
all the posts
because what ended up happening was the
dude would come on
and he would post all these photos of
what appeared to be dead women some of
whom
like their faces and [ __ ] like that were
like all [ __ ] burned
and he was kind of like acting like it
was a game and [ __ ]
and then he kind of went away for a
little while and everybody was like what
the [ __ ] was that all about was that
like a joke or whatever and then he kind
of came back
and the weird thing about it though is
they couldn't really ever tie anybody
to it like they couldn't find the dude
so to this day and like i said this was
a few years back this was 2015. to this
day they're not sure if that was like a
real dude like a real serial killer or
because the thing about it is that all
the photos obviously the first thing
that somebody did was did a google
reverse image search
uh to see if they got the photos from
somewhere else you know what i mean
and the photos were original
meaning they weren't on the internet
anywhere else
uh which could mean
that this is an actual killer and he
actually did take these photos and they
are original and he is the first person
to upload them to the internet
some people have speculated that maybe
it's uh that these were crime scene
photos like that the police took in that
they leaked somewhere and somebody got
them and
you know and then uploaded them
but they don't really look like i saw a
couple of them and then i was just like
okay no i don't want to see this today
but
they don't they don't really look like
crime scene photos in the sense that
they don't have like the little rulers
and all the other kind of you know stuff
that they don't have that
but so nobody really knows
uh if this was a real thing because the
dude hasn't posted
uh since then
so
again i just wanted to bring that up i
didn't want to go like too much into it
because there's a couple videos about it
on the internet yeah but
yeah you hear that i have i mean
hopefully the [ __ ] weather doesn't
the stream won't fall it's [ __ ] you
because man last night although it was
kind of late last night it was like it
was more like 10 or 11 o'clock it was
like oh my god it stormed so bad i think
it hailed for a few minutes too like it
sounded like it like out on the roof but
yeah i didn't want to get too much into
that but there is like if you look 4chan
serial killer somebody has archived like
all the posts because reddit or 4chan
rather took them down
um because obviously violated their
terms of service uh you know after a
while they were left up for a long time
and people were playing the game the
weird thing about it though was that the
first woman that he had posted the
picture of
they like some people did some sleuthing
that woman actually was murdered they
did find that body
uh they found it in the street but she
died from 17 gunshot wounds i think
she'd been shot like 17 times and from
the picture
it didn't look like she'd been shot that
doesn't mean anything necessarily
but
it is kind of weird that
so i don't know if this is just some
sicko like making some [ __ ] up because
he knew that that girl had been murdered
and he's like oh i'm gonna do this funny
thing and
i don't know the pictures look pretty
[ __ ] real and they're pretty [ __ ]
gross
like i said you can't find them if you
want to i'm not like [ __ ] putting
them up or anything but
uh but yeah so i wanted to bring that up
but just
search 4chan serial killer on youtube
and there's like a little little like 15
minute like breakdown about it which is
actually kind of interesting but
you know that there's that
so okay so the first one i want to talk
about
is hopefully i can get through all of
these without falling asleep or without
the [ __ ]
you know
cut shutting off because of the storm
but uh you know
so are they still talking about movies
oh okay israel keys oh yeah we did a
show about israel keys uh
gosh it was a long time ago i think i
kind of feel israel keys is like one of
those serial killers that like nobody he
seems like he doesn't have much name
recognition which is strange because
that's an unusual name you'd think
people would remember it oh it sounds
familiar but even though
even though he murdered like a [ __ ] ton
of people yeah and he's just one of
those
and i think we talked about this when we
did the show about him it's like why is
it that some serial killers
kill three or four people which is bad
enough for christ's sake but then
everybody remembers them like forever
and then like you have dudes like that
that kill like a dozen or more
and
they're kind of one of those ones that
like
come up on [ __ ] rancor lists like
serial killers you've never heard of you
know what i mean
that have killed like way more people i
don't i don't know what it is you gotta
have a certain kind of pizzazz to be
remembered i guess i don't know but the
weird thing about it it's like i've kind
of thought about this a lot probably
more than i should
but
it's like some of the serial killers
that everybody remembers
or didn't really have any pizzazz like a
personal pizzazz i mean i could see
somebody like [ __ ] ted bundy okay
fine because he was like kind of good
looking and like he had this whole i get
that um you know i get ones that had
like a stick or a gimmick like john
wayne gacy
um you know hey i'm a clown i get that
but because there's something for you to
latch on to there's a detail to remember
maybe it's just that israel keys is just
like a generic looking white guy yeah
and he just like killed a bunch of
people and was just like yeah i [ __ ]
did that and he didn't do anything like
he did horrible [ __ ] but he didn't do
anything that was like
distinctive yeah is that [ __ ] up to
say isn't it okay brian got back to me
talking about uh
scott the guy who jumped off the
table tony's got him tony
i asked why he did it why he jumped and
he said he was suicidally depressed
well yeah i figured but we don't i'm
just saying i'm pretty sure from what i
remember he did leave a note but his
family did not want it publicized
understandably yeah um you know you know
what it's all kind of that's all he's
that's all he's that kind of like
personalized i mean you have to be
pretty depressed to jump off a [ __ ]
bridge honestly if i was going to kill
myself i absolutely would not jump off
anything high because [ __ ] that
i don't
i don't like heights at all
well we talked about this did we talk
about this on the show or were we
talking about this just like off the
show what where um people that commit
suicide and like by jumping off
buildings yeah i don't know why you
would want to do it that way
but what you said well i said that and
because i'm well i'm terrified of
heights that's why i was like if i was
gonna do it i'd do it like with [ __ ]
sleeping pills or something i'm just
going to sleep it'll be fine but um you
know what i mean but they want to make a
[ __ ] but you said that well some of them
feel like they won they need to like
punish themselves because they feel like
they're not and yeah i get that
but
they want other people to see and they
want other people to see it too yeah so
there's that so there's a lot of other
things going on and i just like i don't
understand it because i don't feel like
that
you know what i mean like i said if i
was gonna kill myself i would do it like
in some [ __ ] quiet ass like painless
way but um for when i was living up in
boston
one of my uh neighbors at the apartment
complex i lived in
she was a mental health expert
and she would
she took care of outpatients
and uh she told me that a lot of times
that when they commit suicide because
they want uh they feel they need to be
punished
and she told me a story about one girl
who had been like sexually abused by her
dad for a long time and she had
evidently mixed feelings about it
and she felt like she needed to be
punished about it so she um
got into her bedroom
and poured gasoline all over the bed and
set herself on fire and she danced in
the flames for a while
until they killed her and she inhaled
flames that's why she died
i mean and because she she felt she
needed to be purified by flames well see
that's the thing and i kind of feel like
that's fairly common um with people that
have been sexually abused when they were
younger
um because when you're a kid you don't
really know that that's not your fault
that it's just like a bad because you
inherently you're supposed to like
inherently trust adults so if they're
doing something
to you that you don't like it must be
your fault somehow yeah um so
i because i've known people that uh you
know were victims of sexual abuse as
children and
you know even as adults it takes a
really really lot to get over that it
takes like a lot of therapy to get over
the fact that you think that you did
something to like deserve that which
obviously you did not
but
if it happened to you when you're a
little kid i mean that's gonna [ __ ] you
up your entire life you know for her it
was not just their little kids like a
long time that's what i mean and like i
said sometimes it's like prolonged
and that's even worse because
then you kind of get into a thing where
you're like guilty like you thought you
had it coming at first and then like
well i didn't stop it so maybe maybe on
some level like i've enjoyed it like i
kind of so you get that kind of weird
[ __ ] going too i get that that's what
she said yeah that's what she said so
she felt guilty because she was kind of
conflicted about it so she [ __ ]
burned herself alive used gasoline i
mean that's so sad but i mean i can see
she's in her 20s i can see how like
because man i gotta tell you you're
[ __ ] your own brains your own worst
enemy yeah
mine certain mine certainly is
granthar says two co-workers of mine in
law enforcement ate their guns
harsh yeah i kind of feel like that
happens a lot well you're working in a
high
high stress environment seeing the worst
of humanity
i could never be a cop
i couldn't be a cop because second i
don't think i control myself bishop i
guess around some really [ __ ] up case
i try to become the punisher and i'm
like [ __ ] you're not coming out of this
[ __ ] alive i'm gonna kill you
i'd imagine that situations like that
law enforcement actually probably kind
of rare
because it's
i've seen the videos you know [ __ ]
the shooting video you know of the
[ __ ] actions arrests gone wrong or
shootouts it's not a kind of it's not
really the kind of situation where you
you have time to think about it uh but
so if i got a hold of a [ __ ] serial
killer
the thing is it's not in the heat of the
moment a lot of times like it looks like
they're they're apprehending a serial
killer and the dudes that are
apprehended don't really know the extent
of the crimes
or
they're already kind of mentally
prepared to apprehend the guy
so it's not as shocking you know so
you know so you just arrest you're just
doing your job
i can see that but there are some dudes
i'm like ma'am i meant to [ __ ] kill
you i kind of feel like it might
i don't even think if it was me i don't
even think it would be just that because
if it was like a bad person i'd be just
like yeah [ __ ] you whatever i think it
would be because cops have to deal with
like you have to deal with the victims
all the time too and even stuff that's
like victimless crimes like [ __ ] car
accidents and [ __ ] like that so you're
gonna see
you know here's this little baby got
[ __ ] crushed under a [ __ ] car and
[ __ ] so you'd have to see [ __ ] like that
every day and it's like i can see that
really like not even like just having to
deal with criminals all the time which
they do
which is not good but
just dealing with like just everyday
shitty tragedy i don't think i could
deal with dean coral
that his name dean coral the candy man
yeah yeah yeah i'd have to [ __ ] kill
d carl with a glass rod up in his peter
[ __ ] you know i mean i just i just i
just no we were talking about that
earlier because because some people like
that
it's like you kind of and this is kind
of why because look i have that
vengeance kind of [ __ ] too i read about
true crime all the time i write about
your crime and it's like some of these
people i'm like holy crap like this dude
really needs to be like [ __ ] nailed
to a board and eating alive by fire ants
but
um
i kind of feel like in a way
is that going to help they're not going
to learn
anything
i kind of feel like people like once
they get past a certain point
you're not gonna teach them anything by
doing that and they actually might enjoy
it
so i don't know i'm really conflicted as
much as i would enjoy
taking somebody that had done something
so horrible and like you know flaying
them alive or what have you yeah um
i don't know i kind of feel like that'd
be more for me
and not them because i don't really
think they're gonna learn like oh i'm a
bad person i'm sorry you know they're
never gonna look at a dude like
understand that they're a doubt but a
bad person they're looking at dudes like
dean in the [ __ ] case you know and
the details of that case and you look at
the american criminal justice system
you're like no man there's no way you
can [ __ ] find justice to get even
with that dude then you [ __ ] go look
at like the saudi system where they
[ __ ] behead dudes you were like dude
even beheading that guy is nothing
compared to what that guy did you got to
go back to the medieval era where they
would [ __ ] tie a dude down and saw
him in half with a [ __ ] saw
and you'd be like that's kind of closer
to what that dude deserves
but even that wouldn't really approach
it because that dude did that kind of
[ __ ] to like [ __ ] what 15 20 dudes 20
little kids guys young guys
so you still would never really get even
with that guy you never really failed
you'd never really feel like justice was
served that's what i'm saying yeah you
know that's kind of like that's that's
where i'm coming from with it like i get
the thirst for vengeance i have that too
yeah um but
you know after a certain point you're
just kind of like well am i just as bad
as him because i'm like enjoying this
and he's not
learning anything so i like you said
that thirst for vengeance i'm not even
talking about justice i'm at that point
i'm like yeah [ __ ] justice vengeance
it's like you know what that what i did
yeah you're just trying to like inflict
[ __ ] that dude yeah some of the pain
like a modicum of bro that he inflicted
on somebody else right and then you go
well i don't know if i'm as bad as that
guy and you know what
with that dude i don't care if i'm as
bad as that dude when i'm dealing with
that dude i don't care
that [ __ ] needed to suffer i
mean that was that [ __ ] was
truly evil to make one brother beat
another brother to death to avoid the
[ __ ] pain of what he was doing no no
no that [ __ ] i would have to
just try i'd have this instinct in me
just tried to become satan himself
to deal with that [ __ ] i mean i don't
care if it makes me as bad as him
look it's like i'm [ __ ] as far as some
crimes go
like i understand
you know some crimes where nobody got
hurt i don't give a [ __ ] about that like
yeah obviously they should be like you
know punished and stuff but it's like
don't do anything like excessive that
[ __ ] was the devil but yeah well
no what i was saying was that
and i understand too like crimes of
passion again not good
um you should be punished for it but
you know that's it's understandable like
a lot of people would probably would
maybe do the same thing in the same
situation not everybody but a lot of
people would but then you have
[ __ ] like these [ __ ]
that like very deliberately yeah go out
and they and they know what they're
doing they know what they're doing is
bad and they
just deliberately go out and like find
somebody that they're gonna do the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] imaginable to
and
they get off on other people's like on
innocent people's suffering
those people
i honestly i don't really think people
like that can be helped
uh to a large extent i really don't
think people like that can be helped um
you know there's some wiggle room there
i suppose
there's some good comments in there but
people that are serial killers
uh we've kind of talked about this
before i don't think that it's
necessarily inborn but i do think you
have to have
some sort of inborn component that is
exacerbated by
something in your upbringing it was it's
not necessarily like a shitty childhood
because not all serial killers were
had shitty childhood some have had
completely normal childhoods um
so there does have to be some genetic
component i do think that it has to be
like those two things working in tandem
for you to get that kind of person and
that kind of person
if they're just a pure associate if they
can't feel any emotions
i'm not really sure
how you could reach them like i'm not
sure how they could be fixed i'm not
really sure how they could be helped um
so i don't really know
you know i i don't think they could be
rehabilitated most criminals i think
probably could be um you know depending
but serial killers
of the type that we're talking about
that we've talked about in the show not
so much i i just don't think there's any
i don't think they can help them
uh thank you very much ian england you
do bad [ __ ] to people so other
bad people will think twice
um
i guess but uh honestly though i kind of
feel like that maybe doesn't
work on a one-to-one basis because it's
like you know a lot of countries like we
have the death penalty well not all the
states have the death penalty but a lot
of states have the death penalty and
honestly even states have the death
penalty like their crime doesn't really
seem to be any lower so i don't really
think anybody is i don't think it's a
deterrent is what i'm saying i'm not
necessarily against it in extreme cases
but
you know i i don't think you should say
that oh it's a deterrent for other
criminals because i don't actually think
it is
um
you know and it just doesn't like our
justice system is so like [ __ ] up and
like weirdly
uh you know
who gets it and who doesn't get it it's
just like all over the place
so
i don't know it's just a whole thing
this country is so large
that you can't really have any
rules across the board you know what i'm
saying
um
[Music]
john gore says i had a great childhood
my adolescence though yeah i mean
i you know i was
poor but it's like we had i had a good
childhood my adolescence wasn't didn't
have anything to do with my parents my
parents were awesome but
um
you know i got bullied some but you know
people got bullied worse than me though
but you know
that's kind of a thing but if honestly
if i'd had if i'd been born with the
propensity for like not having any
empathy or sympathy for other people
like i said i do kind of feel like
that's maybe a genetic thing if you
don't have any empathy i'm not really
sure how other humans can approach you
so i don't know how that can be fixed
yeah
lane england says you do bad [ __ ] to
other people so other people other bad
people will think twice thank you very
much ian that's right
i'm not saying though like if somebody
did something to me personally
and i've said this before like if
somebody
did something to me personally or did
somebody that i love uh did something to
somebody that i love personally um i
would take great delight
in uh cutting little pieces off of them
and eating them in front of their face
but you know or you know making them do
a stew like while they were still alive
or whatever it's just like cutting off
little pieces so i would like take great
delight in doing that and i'm not
i'm not like ashamed of saying that you
crazy no i'm just i'm saying john smith
says there's a guy in pakistan was
sentenced to be dissolved alive and acid
for killing 100 boys but was ebstein's
in jail hung himself after breaking both
his arms and legs okay
man
that might be an
interesting case but the problem is
probably can't get it in english
yeah i might i'd have to like dig down
at it so maybe somebody like did a
translation of it right you'd be
surprised the true crime community is
pretty uh on top of [ __ ] not always
there are some cases that it's hard to
find translations guys said maury troy
trovis another
little known serial killer tied women up
videotaped and audio taped them before
killing yeah he committed suicide
immediately i mean there's an alarming
number of these dudes and like i said i
think i said this before because
remember when i was writing the faceless
villain books and i was just kind of
like
especially the third one the second and
the third one
which were uh you know from mid-century
like uh 2000s or you know mid-century
from 1900s on and i was just kind of
like
after a certain point you had to stop
looking because there were just so many
there were so
many like unsolved murders and that
doesn't even that i didn't even like get
into like the solved [ __ ] of which they
were like you know exponentially more
unsolved crimes they were just so
[ __ ] many it's like i had to leave a
lot of them out because it's just kind
of like boy it is coming down out there
yeah it is dagobo is a [ __ ]
right now in florida raining
raining it's not hot though at least
just brandon yeah that's nice
camp guy said i saw a serial killer
expert on youtube that said he expected
there was a torture dungeon in every
large neighborhood he drove by
you know what that one
well that might be a slight exaggeration
but you know what i don't know if it's
that much of an exaggeration
every major city has at least two
operating i think is what they said
last i heard this that sounds about
right that sounds about right that
information is from the 90s though and
like i said yeah and i kind of feel like
serial killing has
is on the decline
um the situation isn't the same yeah
because like you know yeah culturally
it's not really the same kind of like
mass shooting obviously that's kind of
more of a
and
thing
but
define mass shooting is very different
too
gang bangers [ __ ] shooting at each
other and shooting that i don't consider
that to be a mass shooting well that's
not it's not
the same motivation
it's not the same motivation right
that's why i usually and that's why like
when i did like i said when i did my
faceless villain books i usually left
out like gang shootings political
assassination stuff like that because
it's like
obviously it's not good somebody got
murdered but
there was a motive behind it it was a
practical quote-unquote killing it
wasn't
the kind of thing where it was just like
random i'm just going to like you know
charles whitman i'm going to go up on
the wall he had a brain tumor but you
know what i mean i'm going to go back to
the top of it not guilty yeah i'm going
to go up on the top of like a tower and
just like start shooting at random ass
people for my own like weird [ __ ] up
reasons um so
i i was kind of more interested in that
where [ __ ] was like almost like
like there was no reason because to me
that's like more interesting yeah if you
have a reason it's like hey that dude
like disrespected or he like didn't pay
me or whatever and you go and pop the
dude that's that's bad but that's
everybody understands why that happened
well graham's back me up on this most of
it has nothing to do with getting paid
or not paid it's predictable people in
predictable places at a predictable
[ __ ] time
it's always [ __ ] very predictable
what they do it's usually [ __ ] talking
because they're [ __ ] talking that's
talking [ __ ] well yeah it's like it's
it's not even it's it's not your
disrespect yeah it's not even somebody
heard you were disappointed yeah yeah
you talking like [ __ ] i got the new
car and you're talking [ __ ] [ __ ] this
it's not even
business related most of it just [ __ ]
[ __ ] talking because they're they're
kids and they're [ __ ] stupid they
come from nothing you give them one
little thing and they want to fight over
it
but like i said that's understandable
yeah and if you have nothing they have
nothing and they start fighting over
nothing and uh
but in a way you could say there's an
evolutionary bottleneck going on there
in a way there's a certain kind of
person that does not pass go
and you know race really doesn't have a
lot to do with it it's just
yeah it's taking place in certain
[ __ ] neighborhoods
and it's a certain kind of [ __ ]
culture but it's also a certain kind of
dumbass
yeah i mean you have the same people
that from right from that neighborhood
that think this shit's [ __ ] stupid
they're not doing that it's just
dumbasses
like [ __ ] a couple weeks back
some [ __ ] shot at another [ __ ]
downtown
because he thought
that guy was talking [ __ ] about him on
facebook
and he missed that dude and shot the
girl that was had nothing to do with it
she landed that's right but she lived oh
great you know good thing that she lived
but
just dumbasses you know dumbasses
i mean
don't let like
dudes up to the age of like 35
don't give them any [ __ ] weapons it's
not no that's not what it was because
they're all [ __ ] well no he was
underage he was 17. well yeah that's
exactly
what kids are kids are stupid yeah he's
stupid kids are stupid yeah um and they
do stupid [ __ ] yeah
when because they i kind of feel like
they don't now that we're like old and
crotchety yeah you know your actions
have consequences i kind of feel like
when you're young
maybe you intellectually know that but
you don't like really know that yeah you
know what i'm saying another one that
happened uh in our stomping ground
downtown orlando
dude got [ __ ] rip-roaring shit-faced
drunk standing up at the bar uh orange
it was orange ave right for washington
he's on washington well orange okay so
orange is just this way and washington's
this way this is where i was so the main
drag was washington is orange orange
okay on orange
a couple there's a couple buildings down
from my bar
[ __ ] gets just [ __ ] [ __ ]
drunk can barely stand
and reaches in his [ __ ] waistband
pulls a pistol out and sets it on the
bar
the bar [ __ ] clears out well yeah
[Laughter]
he gets up in the empty bar and starts
walking towards the door
well
they called the cops right well yeah
obviously the cops see him coming out
the door and [ __ ] shoot him right
through the door
miss him no no yeah they missed him
didn't they and shot the [ __ ]
bartender that was standing behind him
the bartender girl
yeah
dumb [ __ ] what was wrong with the dude
dude was [ __ ] drunk why did he have a
gun all right he's just some dumb ass
because he was a dumb man just dumb ass
goes to the [ __ ] goes to the
he evidently wasn't threatening anybody
he just got [ __ ] pissed [ __ ] drunk
and started staggering out with a gun in
his hand
although i would argue that um you got
to be dead that any like sane person
would see that as kind of threatening oh
yeah because you don't i don't blame the
cop i don't blame a cop it was just a
bad shot it was a bad shot i mean i
blame the cop for just like shooting
blind like that because it's just and
not realizing that it might hit somebody
else i mean yes it's the heat of the
moment
and [ __ ] it missed that missed him
and shot the girl standing behind him
but i mean you know and she was quite
you'd probably be mad if like if that
was me and i was oh yeah
yeah so
i wouldn't that was somebody's
girlfriend or sister or mom or whatever
so
yeah that's no consolation to them i'm
not just saying she didn't have anything
to do with [ __ ] no but life is a lot of
life is random
it is a lot of it's just it is that's
not a fun thing to think about yeah
me and jenny were driving back home
and ran up on a on a [ __ ] pile up of
cars oh i remember that remember that
and i'm like what the [ __ ] we were
coming back from tampa yeah well yeah
and guess what people i was [ __ ]
ripped i was [ __ ] ripped well we had
other people who were we driving home no
it was just me and you
i was i thought somebody else was on the
car with us just me and you i was
[ __ ] ripped and it wasn't from tampa
we were coming back from we were coming
back my bar
and we come up on a damn pile up
oh you're talking about it you're
talking about a different situation slow
down i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
thing i'm trying to take in i'm trying
to take in this
and a car in the right lane the slow
lane
passes me and [ __ ] annihilates the
car right in front of me and i'm like
what the [ __ ] and two seconds later a
truck in the fast lane goes and hits
another [ __ ] car and i'm looking at
the dude behind the wheel when that car
hits him and he was vaporized and killed
i know that guy was killed i saw it
happen
and i just put the car back in first and
went around the pile up
yeah
yeah that's it
i was we were the first ones there i
went around the pile up
and [ __ ] looked in the rearview
mirror and saw a couple more cars
[ __ ] hit that pile up
i know some people got killed there
well and [ __ ] this is that was random
as [ __ ] and i don't like to drive on
yeah that was random as [ __ ] well it's
not random because people are doing dumb
[ __ ] it was saturday night everybody
everybody was [ __ ] loaded
every one of those people in that pile
up were drunk
and [ __ ] that dude i was looking at
when that he was in a truck and a pickup
truck and another pickup truck hit him
and i saw that dude just
vanish that that car had to be going 80
when it hit him
boom he could have survived i didn't
know what hit him yeah
and i was like i'm getting out of here
and i drove into that pileup and went
around those cars and looked in the
rearview mirror and saw a couple more
cars hit it
was that [ __ ] random it was totally
[ __ ] random that could have been me
and jenny in those in those cars
yeah and i was like the first one of the
first people to pull up to it
that was what four or five years ago now
i don't know well when you first started
talking about i thought you were talking
about the time we were driving from
tampa
and the road was empty and we were just
going along whatever and somebody was in
the car with us we were driving
something yeah and i passed that car we
were driving was it stacey yeah stacy
was yeah it was stacey she was in the
back or she was driving she was in the
back seat and or she was driving at
first and then she was driving like she
was too drunk crazy and i said yeah um
can you pull no you were sleeping in the
back seat
you weren't saying anything all right uh
you're really [ __ ] up so she was she
said i'll drive i'm i'm sober and she
was driving and i'm like
you're not sober please pull over so
like i got the driver's seat and then
there was like uh yeah there was like a
car
stopped in the middle of the hike there
was nobody there was nobody on the road
it was like four or five in the morning
nobody and then all of a sudden there
was like a car stopped right in the
middle of [ __ ]
i-4
yeah it was that i remember that one
yeah that was a long time yeah but i'm
just saying yeah yeah it was later
because i think we pulled it over and
like you got in i got in the front seat
and drove yeah
because but they just can't drive when
they're drunk i drive pretty good when
i'm drunk and stacey absolutely could
stacy she was she was scaring the [ __ ]
out of me stacy well she told me yeah
that she was so she seemed sober because
she's like look i'll buy you guys some
tacos and i was like okay cool we bought
tacos from a taco truck and then we were
like driving and she's like driving she
was all over the [ __ ] place and i'm
just like oh stacy was this big wild
[Laughter]
stacey was this big wild pretty [ __ ] we
used to [ __ ] hang off hang out with
off and on she was i haven't seen her in
years you haven't seen her she married
some dude in australia and then divorced
his ass and came back and she and she
was a mensa she was part of that mensa
society you looked at her she looked
like a stripper but she was a uh
a physicist an advanced physicist yeah
but you never know by looking this goes
to show you can't tell just by looking
at somebody right
but we know a lot of people like that
yeah no yeah
so one of the wildest couples we know is
a [ __ ] defense attorney and her
husband
who's an ex-con
and [ __ ] they live with their teenage
kids they're grown now but there you
know that bdsm [ __ ] and they have these
[ __ ] female girlfriends living with
them there's some wow well they got like
a whole dungeon they had a whole day
they're not murderers though no no no
they're just so nice
they're lovely people he look like
mussolini let's call it mussolini a
little bald hit it short dude
but yeah we've had some yeah yeah
there's all kinds of [ __ ]
so can i actually get into the first
case now or what now that i have to go
to
look it's been an hour and a half
talking about stuff other than the
[ __ ] murders [ __ ] okay all right
go ahead all right well i'm gonna go to
the bathroom because right now i'll
entertain him okay just all right
because i'm gonna entertain everybody
okay good
okay i'm gonna go back in the comment
sections while she's in there
okay
graham says i never saw a cop take the
law into their own hands but i did see a
few mouthy bad guys
uh get tuned up with a goon hand to the
side of the face yeah
the cam guy says i saw syracuse okay you
already heard talk about that
um
jason says social media is a breeding
ground for sick people
yeah just look at [ __ ] twitter
uh
john says kids don't realize how long
life is they think they're invincible or
immortal yeah it's true
grantor says there are many
there are many many studies about how
underdeveloped frontal lobes in
adolescents and young childhoods is a
huge factor in violent crime yeah
they're young and they're dumb
rebecca says tonight's topic is kind of
odd for me it took me almost two years
to watch don't [ __ ] with cats earlier
this week it's shocking yeah don't [ __ ]
with cats was a was a good movie
dude was [ __ ] killing cats they
caught his ass though
and then tyler goes hell yeah another
tom fireside chat yeah
man this daylight savings time is
freaking me out yeah i know it's going
there it's like it's still light it's
still light out this is like weirding me
out what's got me upset is that the ice
maker is not keeping up with our ice
demands i got that [ __ ] [ __ ] filled
too it usually does i had it going off i
thought it could get some more ice and
get some more drinks go ahead rickshaw
said don't [ __ ] with cats was real
messed up yeah i had a hard time
watching that honestly
um
you know yeah like people getting killed
is [ __ ] up but that one
i had a hard time watching that
i really had a hard time watching that
um all right so finally finally
now that we're like an hour and 40
minutes in
i told him i was like dude i have like
four cases so
let's let's not go off on too many
tangents did you listen no of course
all right so first guy i want to talk
about uh i thought this would be apropos
we are going to talk about the grinder
killer second
but i want to talk about this guy first
because this guy is called
the internet's first
serial killer
also known as the slave master
and i'm amazed we haven't covered this
guy earlier now he actually the thing
about him is that he did kill a bunch of
people
really before the internet was all that
widespread
but gotta say
if this isn't too weird to say uh he was
kind of like an early adopter
of uh the internet for serial killing
purposes uh which is why they call him
that but he actually did kill people
before
uh you know the internet was all that
widespread but he did use the internet
like after he had a prison so this is
john edward robinson
internet's first serial killer uh not
only a serial killer also a kidnapper
forger
uh embezzler general conman so there's
that as well oh there's my creepy phone
is ringing so there we go
now he actually was found guilty of
three murders in 2003
uh this happened in and around like
kansas uh kansas and missouri
and he actually got the death sentence
for two of them
now later on a couple years after that
like after he was in prison um he
admitted to
a couple more
but
law enforcement pretty sure
that he's responsible for at least eight
but
could be more because some of the people
that they think were victims of his they
haven't found them
and the fact that
they found some like bodies on his
property um
means that there could be some ones
hidden elsewhere that he's not talking
because he is uh very very uncooperative
like he will not give them any
information but he is imprisoned he's
actually on
death row
now uh so he's called the internet's
first serial killer because after 1993
he did actually find most of his victims
uh through chat rooms
so that's why but he had killed people
prior to that so but i'm just saying so
he's kind of like
straddling both worlds i suppose
so originally he's from cicero illinois
now he was kind of like the middle kid
his dad was an alcoholic
his mom kind of strict
although as far as i could determine i
don't think his childhood was
particularly abusive or anything like
that i think it was fairly standard
um 1957 he actually became an eagle
scout
and then went on to enroll in this
like prep school in chicago that was
like a funnel for like boys going into
the priesthood
so which i didn't even know that was a
thing but okay
so he went to that
but he was only in there for a year and
he was apparently like always getting in
trouble so
they either kicked him out or he dropped
out
1961 oh pookie's on the show she's like
why are you carrying me i'm like this is
not
she's being crazy
what was she doing [ __ ] pulling [ __ ]
uh attacking [ __ ] well you know trying
to get me she's just trying to get
attention that's what tangent
[Laughter]
she's like well okay
yeah she's not like you can pick her up
she's cool with it but normally she's
just kind of like i like my own she
likes her own like little independence
you know what i mean she likes to kind
of like run around she's like okay put
me down
uh okay so 1961 i went out there plenty
of ice
okay so so you're
so you uh you need some more ice you
impugned the reputation of our ice maker
for no reason
all right so he goes to
like junior college or community college
as they called it later on
in 1961 and he wants to become a medical
radiographer
but after two years he dropped out of
that too
1964 he actually moved to kansas city
and got married
and had a bunch of kids four kids i
think he ended up happening uh he had
like a son a daughter and then he had uh
some twins like a male and female twins
now uh so his criminal career started
about 1969
like some serial killers not all of them
he started with like a lesser
non-violent crimes uh in this case he
got arrested in kansas city in 1969 for
embezzling
33 000
from
the doctor's office where he worked as a
radiographer
what he was doing was like forging his
credentials and
cashing checks that he wasn't really
supposed to cash so yeah he made thirty
three thousand dollars for that but he
got caught so he got three years
probation
a year later he violated his probation
by moving to chicago without uh the
permission of his probation officer
and he ended up getting another job as
an insurance salesman
uh you know
this kind of kills me because back in
the old day you could probably still get
away with it nowadays if you knew what
you were doing
but it kills me back then
how you could have a police record
you could have no college degree you
could have all this stuff and you could
just tell people stuff at a job
interview and you could just like get a
job
and everybody's like okay i suppose so
and they would just like give you a job
what the [ __ ] man
like i guess people were more trusting
back then but jesus like somebody didn't
care i guess
because it's just every time every time
i hear about like serial killers from
this time period it's like yeah he just
moved to this other city and like got a
job doing this that i'm like jesus
christ really did nobody check
nope
they didn't check
so you know
so uh so yeah no internet
yeah no interconnection i mean you i
don't think you would get away with it
nowadays it was much easier back then
but
i mean now if somebody didn't give a
[ __ ] i guess you'd still get away with
it but you know i think back then it was
much easier so he gets a job as an
insurance salesman
in 1970. uh you're after that right on
schedule he gets arrested for embezzling
again
uh from that company
and uh then at that point they're like
okay well you have to go back to kansas
city now because technically you're
still like on parole and you don't like
reporting your parole officer so there's
that whole thing
uh so they gave him like a longer
probation
1975 they extended it again because he
got arrested again
uh
for securities fraud and mail fraud what
he did in that case
was he set up
a medical consulting company in kansas
city which was like fake so i guess he
was like trying to get investors that's
what he was doing
so uh
in the meantime again because nobody
checked for [ __ ] sake
he was able to become
a baseball coach
a sunday school teacher
and a scout master
don't trust nobody you guys well i mean
specifically back then
um also 1970s i love this 1977
he gets there was like a charity that
was like local to where he lived in
kansas city
he got named to the board of directors
and when he did that however he did that
he started like forging letters from the
executive director to the charity to the
mayor of kansas city
and said that he had got like the man of
the year award
and he even like hosted this big like
luncheon in his own honor
that's i mean
that's pretty ballsy
uh so yeah he hasn't even killed anybody
yet and already i hate this dude
so he's doing that
so his probation was over in 1979
now uh he gets arrested for embezzlement
and check forgery again in 1982.
60 days in jail
so he gets out and because he just can't
like live a normal life like a normal
[ __ ] person
he sets up a fake
hydroponics
company and gets a friend of his
whose wife was dying and was looking for
like an investment to like pay her
medical bills for christ's sake he's
like oh i'm starting this company and
we're going to make all this money he
scammed 25 000
off that guy
so
special yeah so he's doing that
1984 this is when the killing started
he set up two more
like fake companies called equiplus and
equi2
one of the people that he hired for
these fake businesses was a 19 year old
young woman named paula godfrey
she was supposed to work as a like a
sales rep for this fake company which
didn't exist
now
paula
told her family and her friends
that oh you know i got this new job and
i have to go away for training that's
what he had told her
um
now it will probably surprise no one
that after that
her family and friends heard no more
from her
so her parents filed a missing person's
report
now don't
don't hurt that kitty no i just grabbed
him she goes she was yelling yeah she's
like don't yet i'm
i have my own [ __ ] i gotta do i got poop
you don't have your own [ __ ] yet yes she
does she's got protesto
i don't i try not to thwart
the pookie actions
she just does whatever she wants she's a
floor kitty she doesn't really like
she she doesn't mind being picked up and
like laughing stuff but after a while
she's just kind of like okay yeah i
gotta i gotta go back she's got her
whole life but she's got her own she's
having fun
yeah look at her she's like looking like
[ __ ] i'm getting out of here yeah i'm
out of here i got [ __ ] i gotta do she
wants to play with the [ __ ] stuffed
mice
yeah there's a whole bunch of stuff mice
and stuff but also she probably wants to
like scrape on my [ __ ] couch and [ __ ]
over there
but yeah so uh so yeah this 19 year old
young woman disappears so her parents
filed a missing persons report
now the cops
in their defense did actually question
robinson obviously because he was her
employer
um and he's just like i don't know i
don't know where the [ __ ] she is
couple days later
her parents get a
suspiciously
typewritten letter from their daughter
it had her signature at the bottom
but it said
oh i'm okay but i don't want to see you
guys
which
that's like giant red flags or like
[ __ ] waving all over the place but
okay this was like 80s maybe people
didn't know
um
so at that point though the cops were
like okay fair enough and they called
off the investigation because they said
oh well
there's a letter from her she says she's
okay
and she's an adult
so
that's the end of it you know what i
mean even though that's fishy as [ __ ]
getting a typewritten letter from
somebody that doesn't sound like that
being like oh i'm okay don't look for me
signed me
weird i'm just i'm just saying if
anybody ever gets that [ __ ] this is like
reminding me of like that horror of room
1046 [ __ ] where like his mom kept
getting all these weird typewritten
letters she's like i'm pretty sure these
aren't for my kid but okay
yeah it was that kind of thing
so 1985 so she disappeared then and you
know they they actually never did find
her i assume that she's dead
but no one has found her body uh as of
this
stage
1985 uh he's using a pseudonym john
osborne
he meets this girl named lisa stassie
who had a four-month-old daughter
tiffany they were at a women's shelter
in kansas city so he's
a prize of a man going after like some
[ __ ] vulnerable-ass people like this
he says um hey i can give you a job in
chicago and if you come and work for me
i'll pay for your apartment
i'll pay for daycare for your baby
all you have to do
is just come with me to kansas city and
hey
here's a bunch of like sheets of blank
paper how about you just sign your name
at the bottom of these
again big giant red flag but this is
1985.
and this is a desperate woman with a
baby
maybe she's not like thinking about it
too hard i think nowadays he'll be like
absolutely not
what are you gonna do like [ __ ] scan
it like put it on a life insurance
policy and then bump me off or some [ __ ]
like that yeah
sign some blank sheets of paper that's
not weird at all but she did it
now a couple days after that robinson uh
contacts his brother and his
sister-in-law
who
this is so [ __ ] up
so his brother and sister-in-law i guess
um they had really wanted a baby
and they hadn't been able to have one
and they were having a hard time you
know because doing adoption and stuff
like that that's it's a very time
consuming and expensive process
and they uh were having trouble with it
so he said hey
i i know somebody at an adoption agency
they got a white baby
uh and that needs a home
and i've got an inn so i can get you a
baby and they were kind of like okay
cool and he's like okay give me 5 500
and i'll get you a baby
he gave
them
his brother and sister-in-law
the baby of the woman that he killed
saying hey
have a baby
i've got a spare wow
yeah making some money
i wonder what happened to that baby uh
we'll find out yeah she she actually
found out who she was later on because
well they found out who she was like dna
but yeah
so he had like set up like all these
like adoption papers and all this other
kind of stuff he'd like forged some
signatures
um so yeah obviously this baby's mother
never heard from him again
uh but you know he gave the baby to his
brother and sister-in-law so
great
1987. this other woman 27 years old
katherine clampett
now she um
was had been looking for a job
and so apparently she made contact with
robinson he said that he had her a job
in kansas city she was actually from
wichita falls kansas now she had a kid
but she left the kid with her parents
and then moved to kansas city for the
job
now he said oh my god you're going to
like travel all over
i'm going to pay for you to have new
clothes blah
blah uh yeah that didn't happen she was
not seen after june of 1987. she
disappears she disappeared um and as far
as i am aware
uh she is still missing they have never
found her
from 1987 to 1993
uh robinson actually was in jail
first he was put in jail in kansas on
multiple fraud convictions
and after that he was sent over to
missouri because he had another fraud
conviction in missouri and uh some
parole violation [ __ ] going on over
there too
so he was in prison for a little while
in there
while he was in prison though he was
still
keeping up on the criminal grift like he
was doing
he ends up meeting this woman named
beverly bonner who was 49. now she was
actually married to the prison doctor
who he had befriended she worked in the
prison
library uh so
what ended up happening he
befriended her to such an extent that
when he got out of prison
she
left her husband the prison doctor
and moved to kansas to work for his
fake ass company
what he ended up doing
was that uh he got like after they got
divorced like her and the prison doctor
husband
after they got divorced
they arranged for like her alimony
checks
to come to
kansas city like a post office box
and then after that
her family
again never heard from her
he started cashing
her alimony checks
and
for many years and no one was really any
the wiser so there's that
now at this point this is where the
internet comes into play so like i said
this was uh early 90s when he got out
so what he would do uh he was one of the
early adopters as i said in the very
early 90s of uh you know taking
advantage of like some internet [ __ ]
so he would go on like all the [ __ ]
you know
discussion boards and social networking
[ __ ] using the name
slave master oh [ __ ]
sleeve master slave master oh that's
edge lord [ __ ] right there i mean come
on yeah he's like a [ __ ] fat
middle-aged mother at this point yeah
um yeah well i remember the old internet
man the old it was a [ __ ] trip
[Laughter]
i mean uh everybody says pookie yeah
yeah i was just laughing about that
she's gone now every time pookie shows
up she jumped in and she played with a
little [ __ ] stuffed mice for a while
and she's like i [ __ ] i'm out of here
yeah she grabbed her on one hand and
looked at it for a while and then she
would have
the thing that makes me laugh is she'll
pick up the mouse with one hand then
kind of yeah just throw it and then
she'll kind of chase it yeah but then
sometimes she'll sit she'll have it
there and then she'll like sit there and
look at it yeah like she's expecting it
to move like yes it's her look down and
if i really left like it's gonna do
something
and then then she'll kind of poke it and
then she'll be like
yeah
she's funny just cute it's super funny
uh but yeah
so he is so slave master
yeah so uh yeah so he's into bdsm
nothing wrong with that we know a lot of
people that are into that yeah
uh so he was looking for a sub uh
essentially
now one of his first correspondents
online was a 45 year old woman named
sheila faith
she also had a 15 year old daughter
who's in a wheelchair uh her daughter
had spina bifida
so uh so it was that
now what robinson did was that he uh
shows up all you know
big [ __ ] and wealthy and stuff saying
oh i'm this [ __ ]
i'm a philanthropist i have all this
money
um i'm gonna pay your daughter's medical
expenses i'm going to give you a job
everything will be fantastic
blah blah blah
now uh
this the thing about it though is that
sheila and her daughter lived in
california he lived in kansas city he
somehow how char like i've seen pictures
of this dude he looks like a schlumpy
i mean he doesn't look like anything
they wanted to believe i guess
i mean that's the thing well that's why
people like that's why dudes like this
target
vulnerable women that have some kind of
like look i don't have a lot of money or
you know i just got divorced or i have a
kid with medical expense that i have to
take so
people like that they're they want
they're looking for a solution to a
problem
and even if this dude is like sending up
every [ __ ] red flag like more red
flags than [ __ ] anything
um
you know
you're gonna like kind of quiet that
down cause you're like look i really
need
money i really need a place to live i
really need my daughter's medical care
paid for and it's like it sucks it's
like it sucks that people like target so
funny because you'd see these con men
like this [ __ ] trying to con poor
people in into this idea that they have
money
and people like [ __ ]
you know [ __ ]
my mother being [ __ ] ex-state
department going to brazil [ __ ]
i we used to rub elbows with the richest
[ __ ] families in brazil i mean you
growing up around that [ __ ]
i can instantly [ __ ] recognize a
[ __ ] person who's very wealthy and
powerful i'm not seduced by it it
doesn't impress me at all i just take it
for granted
only poor people are [ __ ] really
impressed by that people who've been
around
been around it know that those people
are [ __ ] miserable schlubs just like
everybody else
but
they're easy to detect just by
the products that they have on hand all
the [ __ ] cultural [ __ ]
things that come along with being rich
like that like they have houses
and they have expensive cars
if they don't have that they're not
[ __ ] rich
but the thing is though is that
you got a lot of people that are faking
it
you might have a nice car but you could
be on welfare
i want to see what property well i mean
you could be renting that or that you're
renting you could be like you could have
borrowed it from a family member or a
friend
right um you know there's a lot of ways
to get around that yeah i ran into a guy
in starbucks that would show up every
now and then in a ferrari
and he did seem to be kind of like an
upper-class guy but that ferrari came
and went
some and then he started to come back in
an suv
and i started asking him more about that
ferrari i didn't know any details about
that ferrari
which obviously he rented that [ __ ]
okay that was a that was a fake movie
what he was showing off well honestly
when he had that ferrari he was popular
with the women when that ferrari wasn't
there he was a nobody
see the dudes that buy those cars know
everything about them that's why they
bought them
they know everything the thing about it
though is i kind of feel like
if you feel the need to
show off
then obviously
you're either super insecure about it
yeah or you don't have what you say you
have most dudes that buy those cars are
car dudes they'll tell you what the
displacement is they know what the
[ __ ] the zero to 60 what what the
[ __ ] 60 to 90 performance levels is
they know what carbon fiber is they know
all this [ __ ] this dude didn't know
anything about cars
uh and he couldn't answer any questions
about the maintenance schedule like if i
like means that he didn't own that car
he was [ __ ] around it hypothetically
if i went out with somebody that said
that they had all this money which i
wouldn't because it's like if you say
you have a lot of money then it's like i
don't
then i'm already suspicious
but
if you're all you're doing is talking
about all the [ __ ] that you have like i
have this cool thing and i have this
blah blah then
maybe you do but honestly i don't really
i don't i don't know when i don't like
people like that and two
i'm suspicious because you're a scammer
or you're super insecure or there's
something else going on in my experience
around here in florida there's only two
kind of guys that have that actually own
those cars
a fat old dude who knows everything
about that [ __ ] car he'll sit there
and talk cars with you [ __ ] all day
that's a real owner
he's in his 50s 60s you know what i mean
he's got money another dude it would be
like a middle eastern young guy who his
dad bought that car for him
and that's not a [ __ ] expensive car
from his point of view that's just a car
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about it because
he comes from a super wealthy family and
that's the car that they bought those
guys are easily recognizable that's the
owners
these dudes who show up
40 50 years old doesn't know much about
the car can't really and the car kind of
comes and goes and doesn't know anything
about cars he doesn't own that car he
rented it
he ran it and those dudes don't have
personalities the other two guys that i
talked about they do have personalities
the fat old guy does have a personality
well i mean some people are trying to
like buy a personality right right right
they're like look maybe people will be
impressed if i have these markers of
wealth yeah that i'm like showing off
which like i said immediately that makes
me yeah because at least the arab dude
whose [ __ ] dad gave him the damn car
he has a personality too to him he's
like oh yeah yeah that piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's what my dad gave me and he's
got a personality i mean people that
grew up with a lot of money that have no
idea like they wouldn't even have any
idea like why that was they don't even
give a [ __ ] it doesn't occur to them to
like show off because
they don't need to no people that show
off
are people that need to show off right
for their own reasons
which is why i don't like that kind of
person the quiet [ __ ] who's
white who's [ __ ] being quiet about
the car and [ __ ] kind of bashful and
the car kind of comes and goes he can't
answer any questions about what he does
for a living or anything about that car
knows nothing about [ __ ] anything
high performance doesn't even know about
motorcycles he rented that [ __ ] car
john gore says lots of wealthy people
keep it on the dl without it yeah and
honestly everything i've read and i've
read this about like the english upper
class and [ __ ] like that most of them
just like drive kind of beater cars or
just a regular car they just wear
regular ass clothes designer clothes
they're not showing off they don't need
to show off for anyone it's like because
they know they have money they don't
really have
they don't have to impress anyone it's
like that here dr matt was the richest
[ __ ] his mom built [ __ ]
orlando general hospital i worked for
him [ __ ] took care of his barn and
his [ __ ] horses and [ __ ]
he didn't have a ferrari he would never
show off [ __ ] fr he had a huge man
she didn't all but no they're trying to
keep that [ __ ] on the download exactly
right i mean because the thing about it
i'm with the british on this one it's
very tacky it's tacky to like wave your
wealth around yeah which like i said i
feel like in the uk it's way more tacky
to do that i don't know about nowadays
but in the us it's kind of like more
accepted yeah but i was kind of always
more like along the british lines like
keep that [ __ ] yeah it's it's really
tacky to be like look how rich i am dr
matt had a fleet of cars he had a fleet
of cars like six or seven of them but
they were all kind of like
nice bmws and nice mercedes beds yeah
nothing flashy nothing flashy you're not
showing off like i said no like if
you're rich like get nice [ __ ] don't
have like shitty [ __ ] just because no
sports cars you didn't have porsches or
anything because i kind of feel like um
you know it'd be nice if i was rich but
if i was i don't really i don't feel the
need to like impress anyone because i
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody else
thinks of me so it's like i would just
have like i would have nice [ __ ] that
doesn't break down and stuff but i don't
need anything flashy i don't want to be
like paying attention to me yeah you
know flashiest i don't have that flashy
[ __ ] i ran into was up at starbucks back
at the old starbucks [ __ ] he had guys
with motorcycles showing up and he had
all overweight
dude from saudi arabia who he was cool
and he showed up in a damn [ __ ]
a [ __ ] reproduction ac cobra the
chassis was made in south america or
it's going to be south africa i think it
was called a uh [ __ ] super something or
other i can't remember what he told me
it was but it was this [ __ ] badass
[ __ ] reproduction ac cobra with a
really [ __ ] hot engine in it and it
was all placed came from other cars
there was nothing old about it
um you know it was not a classic car but
it looked like a classic car
and he was up in front for what it was
yeah yeah yeah it's a [ __ ]
reproduction [ __ ] ac cover
supercharged this and he knew everything
about that car so you know he owns it
okay he could tell you everything about
ac cobra and it would didn't try to pass
it off as an original
okay
so there's a big difference you can tell
so
fake rich people never [ __ ] fooled me
they just don't that's what i was
getting too well like i said i don't
like people that show off about anything
right like if you're cool at something
if you're good at something if you're
have whatever like that will come out
you don't have to like go and be like
look how awesome i am yeah yeah they're
not like that i mean
nobody wants that's obnoxious yeah and
that arab dude was rich but that's not
what the point was i mean it was obvious
that he was because he didn't have to
lie say yeah this is a [ __ ]
old [ __ ] retro ac cobra no he said it
was a reproduction
and on the other side of it i like that
rebecca brought up this point too she
said i had money before my now dead
husband stole my inheritance i had a new
truck and a beautiful home but i no
longer have money i still have the home
new small car because i had to sell the
truck not all poor people look destitute
and i kind of feel like that's the flip
side of this because particularly in the
united states you don't have a bunch of
[ __ ] to be broke you don't see this as
much in the uk yeah in the united states
there's a weird i kind of feel like it's
not as bad as it used to be there's a
weird correlation with if you're rich
you must be like a good person or you
must be like smart or you must have like
done something to earn that and that is
not necessarily the case and if you're
poor then it must be because you are a
bad person it's like a moral failing a
little bit
so
i have seen
people in grocery stores for example
shaming people
using like the ebt cards right you saw
that yeah who shamed them
a lot of people do like in line they're
like oh look at the [ __ ] we're paying
for that [ __ ]
like [ __ ] like that what are you buying
is that junk food like people will get
like all up in your ship because of it
i've seen it happen like several times
and
that's kind of thing it's like well they
have nice clothes so obviously they can
afford that is not necessarily the case
you don't know they you know yeah oh
they have a nice car so obviously they
can't be poor they don't you know what i
mean and it's just kind of like you
don't know what that person's situation
is yeah and uh honestly i kind of feel
like the best uh policy is mind your own
[ __ ] business i've seen pretty much
i've seen poor rich people minds are in
i've seen poor i've seen poor rich
people which like what the [ __ ] what is
a poor rich person
i dated a girl named [ __ ] saron up
and out uh she's up in boston
and her family had a [ __ ] big ass
[ __ ] mansion and they were just
[ __ ] on the edge of [ __ ] survival
because they couldn't afford that [ __ ]
yeah they you know hurt a lot of people
beyond their means yeah
yeah and [ __ ] and they're in like
horrible death yeah they had a lot of
[ __ ] when you would look at them you
think that they were a rich family but
they were just on the edge of [ __ ]
survival really so they were poor rich
people
i'm just saying like
in general they lived like [ __ ] whatever
people's situation is
you don't know what their situation you
don't know their life so it's like butt
out it's like none of your business yeah
i don't really understand and like i
said i've seen it happen and i've seen
it happen like grocery stores so
particularly when people are using ebt
cards
and people are like really judge what's
in your cart what are you wearing it's
like it's very weird how people like
police other people's
life like that and i'm just like you
don't know
like maybe somebody gave them that for a
present maybe you know what i mean it's
just like jesus christ and i think i
kind of think there's a thing too where
you know particularly in this country
people think if you're poor
you're not allowed to have anything like
enjoyable like you're not have a lead
have snacks yeah you can only buy like
rice and beans and you'll like it god
damn it you're not allowed to have
potato chips what do you think this is
the [ __ ] ritz carlton good job like
people get like that about it you're
talking about ghetto fabulous yeah
ghetto fabulous is a poor person that
looks rich that's because they spent
their money in in super superficial
stuff well that's fine i guess you don't
have any money i mean yeah you might as
well [ __ ] you kind of will spend your
money on whatever you're looking good
but looking good and being a trader get
a face probably not the smartest thing
but like i said i'm not yeah i can't
judge i spent my money on dumb [ __ ] too
so a lot of get a fabulous people are
[ __ ] secure because their rents were
low and you know what i mean they don't
have any rent to pay for so they just
spend money on [ __ ] clothes and
makeup and getting their hair did and
all that you know
but what's funny about ghetto fabulous
is that
women can pull ghetto fabulous off a lot
better than guys can't because guys you
have to [ __ ] deliver
women basically especially if they're in
the young dating age they just have to
be attractive enough to attract a mate
so
ghetto fabulous is a girl thing a lot
what's more power to him
tammy says like kim kardashian telling
people to get off their asses and work i
saw that i like kim kardashian
a day in her life yeah i
i read an article like i said i don't i
don't follow the kardashians but i saw
that article like on some blog that i
read
and i was just kind of like really this
[ __ ] is like who has never had to work
a dander life and has always been rich
telling people
that i mean yeah she runs a business and
[ __ ] like that i'm sure she works in
some form or another but it's like
i don't know i i'm not taking advice
from somebody that has never had like
got to the end of the month and had no
money in their checking account you know
what i mean it's just kind of like
i i don't know i'm just
the fact that people like that say that
it's like so [ __ ] tone deaf
i mean i get it they never had they were
never in that situation
uh they don't know what it's like to
actually have no money they can maybe
like imagine it
but
they've never been there they've never
actually
like i said i've been like living by
myself in a tiny ass apartment got to
the end of the month and being like
yeah i have a hundred dollars in my
checking account maybe and uh my rent is
650
which like i said it was a tiny like
roach infested apartment and i was like
and i don't know what i'm gonna do you
know what i mean uh she's never and i
don't have any food you know what i mean
so i don't think she's ever been in that
situation so
until you've been in that situation even
if you have been in that situation don't
tell other people what to do you don't
know what their [ __ ] life is don't
give people advice that's like not
solicited i don't understand why people
feel
i don't get it i don't get it i don't
get why people do that
um
you know i i honestly i have never
ever
felt the compulsion
to give
people friends whoever
advice if they did not specifically ask
me and even if they specifically ask me
i really don't like to because i'm like
look i'm not you okay it's like i don't
know all of the details i don't know
your life i don't know what's going on
in your head
um
you know if you're asking me then
obviously you value my opinion but i'm
still very reluctant to give it because
it's like i don't want you know i don't
want to give somebody advice and then it
blows up in their face and then i get
the blame you know what i'm saying
and
there's a lot of factors that maybe i
don't know about so i really really do
not like to i will absolutely not give
unsolicited advice even solicited advice
i do not like to give solicited advice
even if people ask me for my opinion
i have like a big long list of caveats
beforehand it's like look i'm not you
that's you know what i mean well yeah
look how far we got to go i know all
right well you know that's what happened
yeah
so yeah where were we slave master
yeah uh so yeah
so this poor woman 45 who had a daughter
in a wheelchair because she had spina
bifida
so he says
yeah this is where we got distracted i'm
this big wealthy businessman i'm going
to pay for all your uh daughter's
medical bills
uh i may give you a job blah blah blah
move from california to kansas city
sounds good like i said
big red flag but if i had been in the
same situation as her i can't say that i
wouldn't have been tempted i don't know
if i would have done it
but
like i said when you're poor and
vulnerable and somebody seems to offer
you a lifeline
you might take it i'm not going to blame
the [ __ ] victim in this situation you
know what i mean
so 1994 uh her daughter moved from
california to kansas city
and immediately
disappeared
and robinson
this is nice
kept cashing
faith's pension checks for the next
seven years damn
when nobody caught him i guess he felt
like he got away with that [ __ ] i guess
he did
for a while yeah
why do people like this why are they
breathing my air
god damn it this makes me so angry
all right so i wonder if you could still
do that today
well yeah i mean people are still doing
it to this day yeah i think it's harder
right but that doesn't mean i mean i
kind of feel like if you're really
committed to this lifestyle if you want
to call it that then they'll be like
well challenge accepted
you know people are some people are
[ __ ] up i'm not gonna say people are
[ __ ] up because most people are fine
most people are
not wouldn't do this
obviously this is quite rare but you
gotta watch yourself out there watch
your back
pookie's back on the show look at her
little paws oh he's back on the shirt
she's like don't do it stop picking me
up she's like oh okay
she's like i don't okay yeah she's like
i could just bite you or scratch you yes
you don't care
um yeah so at this point uh slave master
let's just call him that
he's uh starting to become kind of a
fixture in the bdsm chat rooms like the
online chat rooms
1999 he offers another job and a
kind of a master slave bondage
relationship like i said not weird to a
woman named isabella levicka
she was a polish immigrant she was 21
and she was living in indiana
now he told her
um you know look i want you to be my sub
i'll give you a job and it's like these
are the rules and stuff and she was like
okay fine
so she moves to kansas city
now at this point robinson uh which i
should note that he's still married to
his wife like he never divorced her so
you know
uh so he gave this 21 year old girl an
engagement ring
and then took her to
the registrar where you get the marriage
licenses right
and they got one
they paid for it
but they never picked it up
so i don't really know
because she was in i don't know how
recent an immigrant she was so i don't
know if she thought they were married
or like if she knew entirely how that
worked because i know like state to
state it's different like sometimes you
sometimes you need a blood test and blah
blah blah i think the blood test thing
is gone um some states still have it
florida doesn't but um some of the
others because i i didn't have to give a
blood taste when i got married back in
the 90s
but
the blood test thing had to do mostly
with like race
it probably did it's probably like a
hold over from that but i'm pretty sure
some states still do it if you guys like
tell me if your state till does a blood
test right for the marriage license
florida does not
um and it hasn't like i i got married in
1995
and i didn't have to you just had to pay
it was it was under a hundred dollars i
don't remember how much it was like for
the license and that was it i don't
remember what it was but i thought that
i i thought that [ __ ] there was a
time when they thought that people of
different blood types and different
races could not
have children that the children would
come out bad or [ __ ] up yeah they'd
look like [ __ ] they would
they would die or something i kind of
it's probably i mean i don't know i'd
have to look into it but i kind of feel
like the laws and that are like a
holdover because it does seem very
archaic doesn't it because i don't why
the [ __ ] would you need a blood test to
get married for yesterday i think all
people of different blood types can have
children i think well yeah i don't think
there's a biological problem i mean
unless you're like brother and sister
right in which case
ew
um but your kids might turn out okay but
then they might not you know what i mean
some states had these weird laws in the
united states about racial cross
breeding
well yeah that was on the books until
fairly recently right fairly recently
but like i said it went state to state i
thought the the blood test had something
to do with that because it probably did
they thought that blood type had
something to do with it it probably did
yeah but yeah so they did um so i guess
apparently i think they were in missouri
at this point
um but they didn't say anything about a
blood test but they did like do the they
paid the fee and they filled out the
form or whatever and they got the
marriage license but they never went
back to get it so i don't know if she
thought that she was officially married
to him or not
um now she did like contact her parents
and said that she had gotten married but
she didn't tell him what her what her
husband's name was
now
one thing and this is i know this is
weird but it's not all that uncommon in
like bdsm relationships
but he gave her
i mean it's weird in this case because
he's a [ __ ] serial killer but you
know what i mean
he gave her this [ __ ]
contract
that had 115 items on it
because she was like the slave right and
it's like all the [ __ ] that she had to
do
right that she had to like agree to
somebody's jumping in and saying the
blood test had something to do with
mental competency
checking for syphilis to make sure that
you're oh yeah maybe maybe that's what
it was we should do a show on that that
might be really interesting that seems
like one of those things that like a lot
of people don't really think about but
like if you look into like the
background of it it's probably like
super fascinating yeah that's make sure
you're competent that's kind of like one
of those things i really like like
looking into because it's something
probably a lot of people don't think of
like i said this isn't a problem anymore
though no i didn't really think about it
too much because like i said i got
married in the 90s in florida and like i
didn't have to do a blood test we just
had to like pay a fee and
it was like 80 bucks 75 bucks something
yeah for the license or whatever
you just had to do that they could just
like marry you right there it was like
official
so
yeah so yes so she signed this 115 item
contract
that said basically that robinson was uh
in control of everything in her life
like he had like all her bank account
[ __ ] like he she wasn't allowed to do
anything like without his say-so that
was like part of the
deal
so she signed it
apparently um not surprisingly
during the summer of 1999 she
disappeared
now one of robinson's employees because
at this point he was like running some
kind of business or whatever said hey
what happened to that 21 year old wife
that you had
oh uh she got caught smoking pot and she
got deported
that's what he said
that's his story yeah
like that was a reality that was never a
reaction well i mean yeah i don't know
if you well you might get deported for
that back then like in the early 90s no
not in the early 90s
if they were looking for another reason
to deport you they might yeah
maybe they're like oh it's an excuse
know
deportation um
you'd have to be like behind well okay
if you're if your visa was overstayed
they would use that to deport you maybe
yeah well yeah
because honestly if you got a visa like
i don't know what it's like nowadays but
um back in the old days they'd give you
if you were coming here to visit
they would give you i think six months
um so you could stay on your visitor
visa for six months and then after that
you know if you [ __ ] up they would
start like looking for you i don't know
it's probably different nowadays i dealt
a lot with um
immigration kind of [ __ ] back in the 90s
and early 2000s because
my assessment was
uh british so he was an immigrant
so i kind of had to like jump through
all those hoops but after 2001 obviously
everything changed
and so i'm not really familiar with the
laws anymore but that's what the laws
were in the 90s
so uh yeah so she disappeared 1999.
around the same time you have this woman
who was a nurse her her name is uh
suzette trouten
and
she
kind of like uh got the sh he like
started contacting her like on the same
kind of like bdsm website
so she was from michigan
and she moved to kansas city to be his
sub
and he says oh we're gonna do all this
stuff we're gonna travel around the
world it'll be awesome blah blah blah
so she goes to
be his sex slave which like i said if
it's consent that's fine but you know
what i mean it's not my thing but okay
now after that uh her mom starts getting
all these letters again typed
again signed by her
um
and supposedly these letters like oh
we're here and there in the other place
like saying they were like all these
other countries
but all of the envelopes had kansas city
postmarks a little suspicious
not really a master criminal but you
know
um
and the mom was like pretty suspicious
because she's like well these letters
like
normally if the ears were from my
daughter they would be like full of like
spelling spelling and grammar mistakes
and they didn't have that
so
she was she was a little suspicious
so um
she contacts robinson's like what the
[ __ ] is the deal
and uh robinson told her
oh yeah um she took off with uh she took
she stole a bunch of money for me and
then ran off with like a friend of mine
i don't know where she's at
so that was his story again he's
sticking to it
now um
so he just keeps doing this stuff
and
as
happens a lot with serial killers he
starts getting a little more uh careless
now by n by the time 1999 had rolled
around um he had started like attracting
some attention from the authorities in
missouri and kansas
and uh
because
a lot of missing persons cases and like
i said
most of the missing persons not all of
them but most of them were adults
which usually they don't investigate to
any great degree if there's no
suspicion of foul play or kidnapping or
anything like that they're like oh well
they're an adult so they took off their
own volition it's fine so they don't
really like investigate them
but
because there were so many cases that
had robinson's name attached to them as
either their like employer or the last
person that had seen them
they finally started paying attention
and i know it's like really easy to say
like in hindsight yeah they should have
caught the connection earlier but
again what are you gonna do like they
didn't really uh you know this was like
the late 90s
so he finally gets picked up in june of
2000.
um he had a farm uh in kansas
what ended up happening why he got
arrested
apparently he was doing some bdsm [ __ ]
with this woman who
i he who he had met online like on one
of his uh
in the chat rooms or whatever they had
gone to uh the farm or the hote or a
hotel or whatever and they had been
doing some consensual bdsm as far as i
could determine but then he went like
too far like and he was just like
beating the [ __ ] out of her
um and she
reported him to the police also she said
that he stole a bunch of her [ __ ] like
her sex toys and stuff
which
i it sounds stupid but those things
aren't cheap so you know
so she was mad about that so she
reported him to the cops
now
at this point the theft charge was good
because then the cops were like okay
well we have something we can like bring
him in on you know what i mean
so they got probable cause they got
search warrants and they were able to
search his farm
when they searched the farm
they found
two
bodies
uh
who were decayed and they were both
women
these were both uh identified as uh
trout and one of the the you know women
that he killed like earlier then like
lewicca the
polish immigrant the
21 year old we get killed a little bit
earlier than that
they were in a bunch of big like steel
drums he had put them in there
so they found two bodies on his property
you know suspicious
yeah very suspicious it's very
suspicious
uh yeah he's probably i don't know who
put those there i'm sure that's probably
what he said
that's not mine but yeah
uh so yeah this was in kansas so this
was like multi-jurisdictional
so they go across the state line in
missouri now they were they had formed a
task force at this point
then they started uh they figured out
that robinson had rented a couple of
garages
so of course they got like permission to
go and like dig around in those
and they found
three
uh big metal drums
in those
and uh those also had
corpses in them
and this is like pretty [ __ ] gross
because i was watching a documentary
earlier that said yeah when they found
some of these
the bodies had been in that they he'd
like put a couple of them in one barrel
this is like super gross i kind of
gagged when they said it but it's like
he put like a couple of them in one
barrel and it's like you put one woman
in there like face down and like she had
decomposed so much that there was like a
foot
of decomposition like
liquid
in the bottom of the barrel
yeah and then there was like and then
they didn't know they thought it was
just one body and they pulled it out and
then like in the sludge there was
another one yeah like at the bottom
can you imagine i do not want what kind
of material what was it some kind of
acid what was it no it was just he just
put him in a barrel i don't think he put
him in there with acid or they just
decompose like in the barrel yeah and
then he just like stuck him in a storage
garage or some [ __ ] like that
so yeah uh these bodies were uh bonner
who was the li uh prison librarian that
he that he had met uh faith the 45 year
old woman with the with the daughter and
faith's daughter she was in there too
the girl with the spina bifida in the
wheelchair what do i have in her ass uh
we did her
yeah um all of them these five women
killed in the same way blows to the head
with a blunt instrument they uh think it
was probably a hammer okay
so
great
great
that's just awesome
2002 this [ __ ] face
stands trial in kansas
for three murders kansas and yeah
[ __ ] kansas sorry if you guys are
from kansas there's a lot of states i
don't have any time for but you know
what i mean yeah kansas is one of my
time for kansas
can't there's nothing in kansas
and there's there's really not is no no
no i can't think of a single thing empty
it's farmland
it's not empty people live there it's
just that mostly farmland that's where
superman came from
that's the only thing
[Laughter]
superman's from there
yeah that's good yeah
yeah you just grow [ __ ] there yeah which
is good i mean everybody needs to grow
some food that's cool but uh
nicholas lamell says they used to call
it bloody kansas yeah honestly kansas
like the midwest in general like just
from me like writing about true crime
and stuff yeah people talk about big
cities and like they're like you know
hells on earth and everything
i'm kind of more worried about the
midwest there's all kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] going on in the [ __ ] midwest
most of the worst crimes that i wrote
about or i read about happen in the
midwest because it's boring like they're
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and yeah i think
that might be why they're like they have
nothing else to do so they're like just
imagining like the weirdest like in a
city you're just kind of like yeah yeah
you're you make me mad but it's like i'm
just gonna like [ __ ] shoot you in the
head or whatever it's robocop crime
right it's like that kind of [ __ ] but
like out in the out in the sticks they
got time perverted [ __ ] they got time to
like come up with some creative [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean
i mean i think i said before like into
even like back in the [ __ ] uh 1920s
and stuff there was actually i don't
know if people know this but there was a
massive rash of like axe murders
in the midwest and i don't think they
were and i think there were several
perpetrators i don't think they were all
the same person
so it was like a lot of axe murdering
going on back then which is [ __ ] up a
lot of it unsolved
yeah a lot of it is well i mean the
valiska one in iowa that's like probably
the most famous but there was a [ __ ] ton
of other ones too
[ __ ] ton of other ones some in kansas
some like there were some some even went
down to like the southwest somewhere to
like colorado and stuff but yeah that's
like a fascinating i don't think it was
all the same person but
it's just weird how that was kind of
like a thing we're all doing axe murders
now even though that's
yikes that's like a really horrible way
to like [ __ ] die it's a really
horrible way to kill somebody so 2002
uh he stands trial in kansas for three
murders and a bunch of other lesser
charges like i said there was a bunch of
other like you know kidnapping rape
[ __ ] forgery all the other kind of
[ __ ] that he was up to
i'm going to give you some another drink
okay more ice
so he gets convicted on all counts
and got
a death sentence for two of the murders
and life in prison for
another one of the murders because uh
lisa stasi
uh one of his victims was killed before
kansas reinstated the death penalty
because like i said a lot of states like
they had the death penalty and they
didn't so there's like a lot of laws
like your grandfather today if you
committed a crime bef when the death
penalty was illegal they can't legally
give you the death penalty so it was
that kind of situation so because he had
killed her when the death penalty was
illegal he could only get life for that
but the other two he got death sentences
for those
now he also ended up getting a 5 to 20
year prison sentence for
interfering
i love this interfering with the
parental custody because remember he
gave that baby away the woman that he
killed and he just gave like his brother
and sister-in-law hey here have a baby
for 5 500
yeah um he got in trouble for that uh
thankfully
interfering with the parental custody of
her baby so he got uh so he got in
trouble for that and he also got 20 and
a half years for kidnapping one of the
victims trouton and seven months for
theft because he was stealing their
checks
now uh he also
because he'd been a busy boy
was also facing some more murder charges
because this was
kansas he was also facing some murder
charges in missouri because these are
two different states
now missouri at this point
pretty um
you know pretty pretty up on the death
penalty we're just we're gonna try and
kill as many of these [ __ ] as
possible
so
you know his defense attorneys were
trying to like not get a trial there
because they thought well you'll get
another death penalty here you're gonna
get killed like lots of times
so uh so there was a whole thing
so they were trying to negotiate with
this [ __ ] they're like okay well
we don't want you to get the death
penalty another death penalty in
missouri on top of the two that you
already got in kansas
so
if you cooperate with the authorities
and tell them where some of the bodies
are because like i said he did kill some
people and they still don't know what
their bodies are to this day
uh you know then we'll maybe give you a
deal we'll just give you life in prison
instead of the death penalty but
this [ __ ]
would not
absolutely would not cooperate
still would not
so he has never told anyone
where the still missing victims of his
obviously he killed them obviously
um but he will not tell anybody where
they are because he's just being
a [ __ ] dick
so at this point what they did
uh they knew they're like look this
[ __ ] is not going to cooperate
he's not going to tell us where these
[ __ ] bodies are
so
what we're going to do
they did a plea deal in 2003
and
robinson i guess they did a thing where
he's like okay well i'm acknowledging
that you guys have enough evidence to
convict me of capital murder for uh for
five of the murders
and
so he said well i'll take kind of like a
guilty plea on that
and the missouri court like accepted as
that
but
they didn't really they just gave him a
life sentence says they didn't give him
death even though he didn't cooperate
with them like about where some of the
missing bodies were
but he did get like a life sentence no
parole that's missouri he had already
got a bunch of charges in kansas
now what ended up happening with this
though
more recently
late 2015 the kansas supreme court
actually
vacated two of the murder convictions
the trout and the stasi murder those on
technicalities
but they did up uphold the uh levica
conviction that little polish girl
and that was a death sentence still
now
uh apparently this because i guess there
hadn't been capital punishment in kansas
but it was reinstated in 1984 so this is
kind of like a big deal for the time so
robinson happily is still on death row
in kansas uh to this day
2005 his wife finally divorced him
i love this
her reasons they were married for 41
years she was married to him through all
of this i don't know why
but um
[Music]
you know i'm i don't know her i don't
know what the situation was
so i'm not like cast i'm not
making any judgments i don't know what
the [ __ ] was going on
but it took until 2005
for her to file for divorce 41 years of
marriage
um and her reasons
are
incompatibility
and irreconcilable differences
irreconcilable differences
my husband is a serial killer and i
can't deal with that yeah it's in
irreconcilable so we're irreconcilable
i can't vibe with his lifestyle yeah his
serial killer lifestyle so i'm just
going to have to like we're going to
have to go our separate ways
it's so
okay so remember how you said about like
the baby that he stole yeah okay 2006
um
that little girl
uh she had been adopted by as i said
this motherfucker's brother and
sister-in-law
and
she was just a baby so she didn't know
any better they had called her heather
robinson now she found out what the [ __ ]
was going on
you know obviously as she would because
it was in the news and everything so she
actually sued the medical center in
kansas city and the social worker that
had supposedly set up this whole like
fake quote adoption it wasn't a real
adoption it was just kind of like you
know
um so yeah she sued
and uh
she got a settlement
for an undisclosed sum in 2007 she also
got a second she sued again and she got
a second judgment the same year
which would prevent a judgment that
would just prevent robinson from getting
any money
from writing a book about the [ __ ] or
you know selling any information about
her parentage or any of that kind of
[ __ ] so she did get that this is her
right here
there's heather robinson
can you [ __ ] imagine
that poor [ __ ] woman yeah jesus
christ yeah
i can't imagine she's just a baby she
didn't know no
she just grew up with these people and
it's like oh by the way
your uncle's a serial killer and he
stole you from like this [ __ ] woman
he murdered jesus christ
i can't imagine it told you
i can't imagine yeah he sold her
i can't imagine what that would be like
like finding that out which is that is
[ __ ] horrifying i don't know i don't
know what i would do in that situation i
just really don't
um yeah so at this point so the the
[ __ ] is on death row and good riddance
but uh some of the people that he
probably killed that are missing still
uh their bodies have never been found
and both kansas and missouri authorities
speculate that a lot of this
motherfucker's time is unaccounted for
so there could be some more people that
he killed out there that they don't even
know about so that's cheerful yeah
internet's first serial killer that's
what they call him
the slave master
all right so it looks like that that was
like that [ __ ] trucker whips and
chains yeah that [ __ ] was taking
pictures who was that like the toy box
killer yeah or was that a different guy
i'm getting all my cereal because
there's so many that i'm getting like my
serial killers whips and changes that
[ __ ] bird that [ __ ] uh was a trucker
and he was running around picking up
girls he killed
he picked up one couple they were like
young teenage couple he killed the
boyfriend in front of the girl and kept
her for a few days dressed her up cut
her hair called her dad and said yeah i
got your daughter
remember that [ __ ] and then [ __ ] he
took a picture of her she's like this
and then later on they found her [ __ ]
killed
tied her to a tree and then used the
[ __ ] garrett to [ __ ] garat to
[ __ ] strangle her used a piano wire
to [ __ ] pull her [ __ ] neck
he said that the [ __ ]
deep
they finally caught in the handcuff they
put in the back of a [ __ ] cop car
they found another victim who was some
light lizard he picked up
and um
[ __ ] he got out of his handcuffs or
got the handcuffs out in front of him he
was able to [ __ ]
step through him
and get his hands back out in front of
him that was some weird [ __ ] but then i
think he got shot i think
during that time i hope he got
he was trying to escape during his
initial arrest i think he got killed i'm
not i think
i mean
people are just been a while since i
looked at that case
but he was he was another [ __ ] bdsm
dude
which like i said and that's kind of
like shitty because it's like oh it
makes it seem like everybody would send
a bdsm is like a [ __ ] freak or a
[ __ ] no no that's obviously no no
and most in most clubs bdsm clubs
[ __ ] for well there's two different
kinds there's a bunch of [ __ ] nerds
uh
those are the ones that are out there
actually out there making videos and
doing [ __ ]
they do the other [ __ ] segment is
basically [ __ ] fashion models
yeah and they [ __ ] gorgeous [ __ ]
people mostly taking photos
wearing [ __ ] fetish clothes
showing up the [ __ ] there's a lot of
that
but you know whether or not they
actually are into the fetish [ __ ]
scene no probably not
or they might just like dip their toes
yeah i don't think they're like really
like hardcore into it but i have no i
know people that are like really
hardcore into it and they're like
they're all like lovely people it's not
i mean yeah but you're going to get your
weirdos in every
scene back in the old days up in boston
up at man ray you know [ __ ] you had
goth night and then the fetish night was
[ __ ] like right after it was
basically the same scene
and um
fetish was kind of like the [ __ ]
sexual orientation for goth at the time
you know
but uh
even people wasn't really much going on
even people that aren't really into it
like look like they're into yeah you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
more fashion than anything else i kind
of feel like it probably is
all right so next thing we're going to
talk about is
uh the one that was actually requested
we're going to talk about steven port
better known as the grinder killer yeah
this is a british fella you better wake
up zach got that grinder killer coming
for you
he's a rapist and seriously yeah
murdering a coral type [ __ ] yeah
well
yeah we'll see we'll see
i'm just teasing this i kind of feel
like he's more like a jet well i don't
even want to say he's like jeffrey
dahmer because there's no cannibalism
involved and honestly i think this dude
jeffrey dahmer
seemed more like sad than anything else
this dude just seems like a [ __ ]
douchebag get out of me
um
they think that he murdered at least
four men did a bunch of rapes and stuff
too so don't forget that now uh 2016
this guy got a whole life order which in
african uk that basically means you're
in prison they're never letting you out
you can't get parole
um
so
uh they're also
the authorities said that they're
investigating a further
now don't get alarmed
a further 58 deaths
that
may or may not be related to this dude i
don't think it's that many
um but because of the method that he
used i can see whether looking into them
as like possible murders
so this [ __ ] who
born in 1975 so he's three years younger
than me
so he's born in south end on c
where i've been actually
uh when he was little he moved to
is it digging him or dagon dagenham
probably i think it's staggering
um now his parents still live there so
that's where he grew up
now when he was a kid
um
he was kind of described as being a
loner
and got bullied a lot
um
and he was very quiet very introverted
where is this united states no england
england okay yeah it's dagging them then
yeah that's what i thought [ __ ]
morrissey [ __ ] saying about dagging
him dead that's right that's right
that's it i forgot i forgot i knew that
sounded
familiar um
interestingly a couple people described
him even when he was older
as being quote unquote childlike as in
like even when he was a grown ass man
he would
yeah he would do stuff like play with
kids toys or he acted like a little kid
which they thought was very like
peculiar
so he left school at 16 and went to art
school
um
but
his parents couldn't afford to keep him
there
so then he went to like a trade school
and he trained to be a chef matter of
fact fun fact he actually appeared very
briefly
on the uk version of masterchef wow so
go back and look steven port steven with
a ph p-o-r-t
uh he was on one of the uk master steps
i don't know how long he was on there i
don't think it was very long
but he might have been one of the ones
that was like eliminated early but yeah
so he was on there
now in the mid 2000s uh he came out as
gay so like i said he was working as a
chef
at a bus depot in uh west ham
and he lived in a flat in london in
barking actually
by himself
what he would do was he would go on kind
of the the gay dating apps like all the
social networks of the time like i said
this is
the mid-2000s
and uh he was also a little bit of a
fantasist
he would make up all these like stories
about his past
i graduated from oxford he would say
uh i served in the royal navy
uh i'm a special needs teacher that was
another one that he would uh say none of
these were true
also super into ghb
you know so there's that
um
he took it himself as far as i know and
also he was a big fan of putting it in
uh drinks that were given to people
because you know
that's facilitating the whole
people being like uh unconscious so you
can do things to them that's kind of
what that thing is for
now his first murder victim we don't
know how many times like he did this a
bunch of times like in the sense that he
would pick dudes up and like dose them
with ghb and then he would rape them
his first murder victim that they know
about
was a 23 year old man named anthony
wallgate
he was a fashions dude
and uh he gets contacted like uh he had
kind of been working as an escort so i
guess stephen like contacted him
and uh he said
he would pay like 800 pounds like for
him to come over and like hang out with
him so they met up at the train station
embarking
and uh
what ended up happening though this was
in 2014 actually
they found anthony wallgate
uh lying on the street outside
uh this dude's
apartment or flat as they say over there
steven port actually called the
emergency services himself anonymously
and said oh hey there's this young kid
that had a seizure or is drunk or
something and he's laying on the
sidewalk outside my house
so he called the authorities
now
this is very sad because i kind of feel
like this is the kind of [ __ ] that lets
serial killers get away with [ __ ]
because it didn't look like a murder
really
the cops were kind of like not
they were kind of like oh well maybe he
overdosed or maybe he was drunk or
something like that so i don't think
they thought there was anything
suspicious right
um
basically now steven port did get in
trouble
for perverting the course of justice or
as we would call it obstructing justice
the same thing
in uh march of 2015
because
what he said on the phone and what the
cops like discovered at the crime scene
were like a little bit different but for
some reason like the cops didn't twig
onto the fact that like maybe that was
because stephenport had killed this kid
even though spoiler alert that's what
happened
uh at the time they were just kind of
like and i don't know because there's
been a lot of kind of uh controversy
over weather and this is you know this
isn't that long ago this only five or
six years ago this happened
there has been some controversial like
maybe the police didn't investigate this
as fully as you know or as stringently
as they might have because
you know these were gay kids or you know
there was like some other kind of [ __ ]
going on you know what i mean it's like
it just looked like they
od'd or
they didn't really see anything
suspicious even though as
we'll see as i go on with the story
this [ __ ] was absolutely suspicious and
somebody really should have like looked
into it
and it kind of makes me mad that they
didn't
but because a lot of people got killed
unnecessarily
but you know there is that
so uh so steven port did get in trouble
for not for murder
but for obstructing justice because his
story like was a little bit different he
just basically said hey there's this kid
and he like
looks like he collapsed outside my house
i don't know what happened
so he got put in prison for eight months
uh but they let him out
like the next summer they did like
electronically tag him though but i
don't really know how
again stringently they followed that
because it really seemed like he was
able to just do whatever and they didn't
really call him on it
so between uh late summer of 2014 and uh
fall of 2015.
stephenport
killed at least
three more men
22 year old gabriel kovari
uh he was actually from slovakia
originally and recently moved to london
20 21 year old daniel whitworth uh he
was from kent he was also a chef
and 25 year old
jack taylor who was from uh dagenham
east london
he was a forklift truck
[ __ ] killing up all my chefs though
yeah well he was the chef also yeah he's
a chef you wanna kill all the chefs
gotta watch the chefs actually gotta
watch everybody watch everybody you
never know
here's the [ __ ] here's the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] though so the first victim
okay i'll give him a pass on the first
victim
the kid was just found in front of this
dude's apartment
all the subsequent victims
were found
in the same area like a couple of them
were like dumped in the same spot like
at the same
church like in the cemetery of this
church st margaret of antioch which is
embarking
they found the victims there which is
right by his house
and they didn't really think to link all
of them together
which
that kills me i don't really know why
that wouldn't happen but yeah
what ended up happening
was that yes so three of the victims
were found there in the same exact
cemetery he was just dumping them in the
cemetery right by his house
by this church right by his house and
the cops were just kind of like okay
suppose so suppose that happens i don't
really know do they find bodies there
all the time i don't know
what steven port did
which
is like simultaneously kind of smart but
also the stupidest thing that i've ever
heard of
what that he did what he did was on one
of the victims he planted a fake suicide
note
on daniel whitworth's body
that said
daniel whitworth had killed
one of the earlier victims and couldn't
live with the guilt so it killed himself
in this suicide note
he also said oh by the way he didn't say
that but it's oh by the way don't look
into that stephen port chap that was the
last person to be seen with any of these
people alive he didn't have anything to
do with it this was all me
which again
that seems like
i don't know that seems like something a
really really stupid person would do
like when they were like trying to be
really smart
i'm gonna write a suicide note and i'm
gonna say oh hey like don't look into
this guy he totally denied it totally
totally did not have anything to do with
it yeah it was that so he did that
which i i love it i love it
how stupid these [ __ ] people are
although the thing about it is that
these criminals are like really stupid
but until still like took him like
forever to catch yeah him so and they
kill people before they catch him
crazy well like i said you were here
when i said
on one of them he left three bodies
in the same graveyard
right by his house
one of the i know you guys have heard
this before but i'm telling him
one of the bodies like one of the
victims he left a suicide note on it and
he said i killed one of the last victims
because i killed that guy and i couldn't
deal with the guilt anymore so i killed
myself oh and by the way
don't look into that steven port dude
that all of us were last seen with he
didn't have anything to do with it
like david believed that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] funny [ __ ] stupid man
yeah
stupid it's funny but yeah i mean
finally
the cops finally like
clued into the got on the clue bus
got hit with a clue by four and they
were just kind of like oh probably
this guy right here has something to do
with it yeah you think you think yeah he
did
so um
yeah
well that's the thing like they did
inquests on the [ __ ] and most of the
stuff because they had so much drugs in
their systems
um
i'll give them the first one okay it's
like he didn't really have any
he didn't have any signs of like obvious
violence on the body i think there were
like some signs like bruising under the
arms which is something that you should
look for like if you're uh you know
investigating a crime or anything like
that because it's like that's somebody
like carrying the body somewhere
obviously it's like
leaving bruising in the armpits so there
was that but they didn't really
see any other uh evidence
of you know violence to the body and
when they did like toxicology and stuff
they found like all this [ __ ] ghb and
all these other drugs in there so like
oh well he overdosed or it was like an
accident or whatever so they didn't
really look like like i said i'll give
them that like the first time around
even though they were wrong
but it happens again and again
somebody should have looked into that
and i will note that the coroner
uh nadia perso
she did say from like the second case
she was like yeah something's [ __ ]
weird about this like you guys should
like really look into it
um you know why didn't you guys they
didn't even like do
rudimentary stuff like why they didn't
take any dna like from the sheet or from
the clothing or anything like that that
he was left with
which would have pointed to the killer
much sooner and probably would have
saved
uh you know a couple people's lives at
least but that wasn't done
so
you know that was kind of a thing and
they talked about that a lot
uh they just thought they oh they od
it's a bunch of gay guys that's what
they do
they ot and like [ __ ] die in the
league and are left in the [ __ ]
cemetery let's okay
that that's kind of like with it but
finally finally they [ __ ] caught this
[ __ ]
um
this dude
he not only drug them with ghb he would
also put like other he'd like uh amble
nitrate um
crystal meth
other kind of [ __ ] so they found all
kind of [ __ ] in their systems
finally they caught him though
uh so at the trial though
steven port tried to argue that he's
like oh well i wasn't really trying to
kill them
so
you know i'm he was trying to like get
some leeway i guess but like the judge
was like yeah i see that but
you know obviously you're giving people
all these drugs so you must have known
that there was some kind of like risk
involved
um
so
no sale uh basically they were like look
you knew the risk was there giving even
if you didn't intend to kill them
giving them this many drugs you had to
know that that might have been a side
effect
and that is sufficient to under uh
english law apparently that is
sufficient to prove murder so he did
actually get convicted
so
2016 late 2016 he gets convicted of uh
assaults by penetration rapes and
murders
uh four murders
and uh rapes of three other men who
actually he drugged and they got away he
also was convicted of ten counts of
administering a substance with intent
even though he didn't get to go through
with it uh and also for additional
sexual assault so there was like a whole
kind of [ __ ] thing
uh so guilty on all counts
guilty on all accounts
so they sentence him to life
imprisonment with whole life order which
like i said
that means uh life without parole
essentially he'll never get out
now uh again i kind of feel like there
was a lot of controversy about this
because
you know some uh lgbtq groups were like
well why didn't you investigate this
well like obviously like all the crimes
were linked they were all the bodies
were found in the same place
same mo
um
you really should have done something
sooner
uh you know so there's that and so
actually in november 2017
uh they actually did open a uh
kind of an investigation into
the police
yeah the treatment of this case is maybe
they could have done something better
because i do kind of feel like they
dropped the ball on this [ __ ]
and this guy
ended up killing
maybe at least two or three people that
didn't
you know that might have been saved if
they had kind of like paid attention to
what the [ __ ] was going on
uh but you know
so
as far as i know they're gonna do
another inquiry uh they announced that
like
like last july or the july before but i
don't know what has happened uh since
then
where they're going to like look into
the police failings on the situation
all right so that's that and
let me see so many sick people online
says one person damn three hours late
we're still i still got like a lot of
[ __ ] show left not really i got like
a slightly longer case than like a
really short one that's all and i'm
still like
pretty much okay
the um
oh uh i just heard word back on beverly
hills cop one on the show that we did
yeah tila saw it she [ __ ] loved it
glad that she did okay and then uh when
she told her husband she asked her
husband [ __ ] she you want to see
beverly hills cop and she [ __ ] caught
hell
because she's like she hadn't seen it
but she said it was great she liked it
yeah i feel like you know like
yeah if you ever catch this one i don't
know if she'll catch this one you know
but if you catch this one you see if i
can park yeah she uh she messaged
earlier and said she wasn't gonna be
able to catch the live oh she was going
to try and be at the live on friday okay
good but for a second when we first
started i thought it was gotta see
beverly hills cop two you don't really
have to see three that much but two two
yeah three i'm just kind of like man if
you want to see it to like to be a
completist but it's not really that good
now who was it that said that one of our
regular listeners [ __ ] said that i
was spot off my analysis of three
and that the 2011 one that they were
going to come out with
rosewood and taggart were gonna be
[ __ ] helping axel out in detroit see
i think
they should have didn't have a good idea
because i kind of feel like a lot of uh
franchises will do that where they do
like the suicharoo you know you switch
into the [ __ ]
yeah yeah like you're switching the uh
the location which i think would have
worked out that the one that he's
working on now is beverly hills cop four
before he's too old to do it but that it
but
even in
2015 the last i heard
and he said that the script has got to
be [ __ ] great before they'll move
forward on it
because well he's pretty aware of what
happened with the last one yeah
so right everyone's very cognizant of
how everybody felt about the lat about
the third one
so
i kind of feel like there's some like
aspect of like redemption in there yeah
and then and if you like the beverly
hills cops and you haven't seen golden
child you got to see that one too that
one was [ __ ] great and it was kind of
like
it's kind of like eddie murphy's version
of big trouble in little china or
or [ __ ]
raiders the lost ark you know it was
it's pretty good i liked it i liked it
mike barrett asked do you like metro
with eddie murphy metro i didn't see
that you know what i don't think i've
seen that i think i saw that one or if i
did i didn't remember it i've seen most
of his movies but i don't think i can
see that one now that i'm thinking about
it
all right so let's talk about this
[ __ ] here
i just found this dude today
uh and somebody mentioned him very very
early on in the chat todd kohlhepp
otherwise known as the amazon review
killer
now he didn't really find his victims
online per se
but people associate him with internet
homicide because
i guess i'm okay i'll just tell you
outright what he did was he posted
uh product reviews on amazon
of
stuff that he had used products he had
used in the course of the murders
like
tools and [ __ ] like knives
uh padlocks stuff like that he posted
reviews about
how much they how awesome they were for
like doing
hold on let me respond on the job that
he was doing hugo if you like the first
bear of the hills cops see part two it's
good it's also good and then somebody
said coming to america is good yeah
coming to america is great so it's the
second one that's also good
um
what was that the other one that they
said
john says i want to re-watch a vampire
in brooklyn i remember digging it
vampire brooklyn's very good one of my
favorite vampire movies it's good it has
some comedy in it but uh no
good flip
very good flick
there were some shitty eddie murphy
movies when they were [ __ ] really
pumping them out but he did have some
good ones even during the shitty period
he had a few good ones and we just
talked about him right now vampire
brooklyn was a good one
yeah i liked vampire and brooklyn a lot
more than what i saw the first time
we just saw it recently yeah
has anyone seen pluto nash honestly
i'm kind of like curious to watch it but
i've never watched it is that eddie
murphy yeah i haven't seen it
mike barrett also says bowfinger now uh
steve martin's in that too right i don't
think i've seen that
one but a lot of people have recommended
that to me like you go saying i'll watch
it i don't know what he's gonna watch
i don't know what you're talking about
you go you're gonna watch what
good
all right so uh yeah so we're talking
about the amazon review killer
dude that you know how you can give
product reviews on amazon right like
[ __ ] you ordered yeah yeah this dude
would kill people and then leave reviews
of the [ __ ] that he used to kill people
like on amazon like not even hiding the
fact that he used the product to kill
somebody with it
so we'll get into that
i just found this today
uh so yeah he's actually guilty of
killing seven people
uh in south carolina between 2003 and
2016.
and of course he's a florida man he's
okay he's from fort lauderdale
south florida in case you guys don't
know
uh so yeah
his uh parents were kind of like they
didn't have a great marriage they
divorced when he was a baby
now
for many years and like i said i always
kind of go into like serial killers
background because i'm curious but this
is not like an excuse because a lot of
people have had like worse backgrounds
than this but
uh so his parents divorced when he was a
baby
um and he didn't have any contact with
his biological father for many years
subsequently
his mom ended up marrying again when he
was three
and uh the stepfather adopted him in
1976.
now
todd and his stepdad didn't get along
which like i said not crazy
um
and so i guess his stepdad was kind of
physically abusive so there was that
uh his mom
divorced the guy and then remarried him
again and then divorced him and then
remarried him again because
third time's a charm i guess
um
but all this time the kid was like look
i just want to go live with my real dad
even though he probably didn't even
remember his real dad because he was a
baby when they got divorced
now this kid though gotta say uh you
know the last couple
people that we talked about now steven
port he was kind of like uh you know he
got beat up a lot and [ __ ] in school
which you know some serial killers have
that uh one before that robinson he
seemed to have a fairly normal childhood
but was still pretty [ __ ] up
um
this kid
seemed like from when he was little
he was messed up
um
he was very uh unstable like uh he had a
lot of like instability when he was uh
growing up
uh very violent very um
he was just like you know
wrecked [ __ ]
he was very violent toward other
children
uh had a you know had trouble like
controlling his anger even from like
when he was very very small like in
nursery school
when he was nine years old
he got sent to a mental hospital
uh and they said that he was quote
unquote explosive
meaning he would fly into violent rages
at with no provocation
uh already very preoccupied
with sexual thoughts and desires
again always a red flag when you're
[ __ ] nine years old when you're
already acting like that
also uh again in the serial killer
trifecta you got here very very cruel
toward animals uh said that he would uh
shoot at dogs with air guns
and would like just kill goldfish like
[ __ ] like that
which
i know some little boys do that and they
turn out okay
but
i kind of feel like when it's sustained
of like i don't advocate it if a little
if i had a son and he did he killed a
goldfish or something like that i'd beat
that kid's ass but i'm just saying
it's like that's i i i don't know i just
said no good is going to come with that
no good's going to come up yet
i don't think they're all going to end
up being serial killers but showing no
empathy toward helpless animals is not a
good sign
uh which is why that's one like i said
that's one of the big trifectas serial
killers other two in case you don't know
starting fires and bedwetting those are
the other things the other two
um so yeah i don't know if this guy had
that but he was for sure curled animals
um so yeah even as a kid
pretty [ __ ] up you couldn't like
really control what he was doing
so his mom uh was kind of like over it
she couldn't take it anymore she's like
okay fine go live with your [ __ ] dad
because i can't deal with you anymore
uh so he goes to live with his dad now
his dad uh was kind of like a playa
uh also big gun nut so there was that
now so todd gets there and he's like oh
my god this dude's awesome but then
after a while um he's like okay maybe
this dude's not so awesome so they
didn't really get along after initially
they did but then after a while
uh not so much
so at this point like todd calls his mom
and says hey i want to come back home i
don't like this [ __ ] anymore
but his mom was like uh yeah no you
already like [ __ ] blew that one you
just stay there so that's what she did
she was [ __ ] sick of his [ __ ] can't
blame her
uh one thing though was that this guy
was um
according to his teachers they said when
he wasn't being a menace to society
uh he was uh actually like pretty
[ __ ] uh bright pretty intelligent
very above average
so there was that
now um
gotta say though he was pretty young
when he first started his
uh rampage if you want to call it that
so 1986 he was still a teenager
he decides that he's going to
kidnap and rape
a neighborhood girl
you know like you do
she was 14
and she kind of lived near him
so this
kid
takes her from her house tied her up
with a rope
and then brought her to his house
and then raped her
and then said if you tell anybody
i'm gonna [ __ ] torture you and kill
you
but she told on him anyway good for her
so he gets picked up by the police
and they question him
and he said this was his excuse
well yeah i did it but um i didn't like
mean to do it
uh my dad's abusive and this was my way
of like getting back at him like my dad
wasn't there for me so
i needed to rape somebody i guess
now his mom
comes there and sticks up for him oh he
didn't mean it he's really a nice kid
blah blah blah
uh she wrote a letter to the [ __ ]
probation officer and everything go easy
on
he feels bad
so uh you know to an extent that worked
because of course it did
uh so they dropped the sexual assault
assault charge which is [ __ ] up
but he did go to prison for kidnapping
like i said he was still a minor
now uh they let him out and he was
registered as a sex offender
uh he gets sent to prison for 15
years
1987 they do a psychiatric exam in
prison
and they say that he's actually like
really smart superior intelligence
uh but also has a highly anti-social
personality
and uh maybe not so great for him to be
running around
now he was in a prison rehabilitation
program well he was in there they taught
him a computer like computer science so
we got a degree in that
they said okay well when you get out you
should be able to get a job it should be
all fine so he gets out in 2001.
and he moved to spartanburg in south
carolina uh soon after he got out of
prison
2004 he enrolls in the university of
south carolina upstate
now one of his teachers that they
interviewed after the fact said yeah he
seemed like super bright super
intelligent um he didn't seem weird in
any way nobody thought that he was
strange or violent or anything
in any way like remarkable about him
another girl that knew him at the time
said pretty much the same thing he
seemed like a decent dude
um you know we never thought that he
could do anything like that see like i
said can't trust anybody
2006 he actually got his real estate
license and became a certified real
estate agent
uh he had worked as a graphic designer
for a short time i'm a graphic designer
too that doesn't mean i'm a serial
killer but you know
they got him in all professions i guess
um
now he actually ended up buying a house
uh you know and he had again he was very
very smart
and he had a good like a real estate
business going for a little while
and uh all of his friends thought that
he was just like a great guy man he like
works hard he's got decent money he's
like good at his job
uh but some of them said well he's a
little bit creepy but nothing overt
nobody was all that alarmed about it
um not enough to like cause any alarm
but
november of 2016
there's this young woman named kyla
brown
and uh she gets found
on todd's property by the authorities
she was still alive but she was uh
chained up like a dog
so todd gets arrested
a couple days after that while they're
searching this dude's property
they find khala's boyfriend
buried
in a shallow grave dead
on this dude's property
he had been shot
multiple times what year was this 2016.
i remember this i remember when this
happened 2016. they found her in the
damn storage container didn't they i
don't know if it's a storage container
they just found it chained up yeah i
remember when this happened i think
so
uh
so the cops like come to todd like what
the [ __ ]
as they would yeah
and todd says oh uh by the way
here's some more bodies
so he leads them to a couple more
these two victims were a couple a
married couple johnny and megan coxy
they had been reported miss back in
december of 2013
uh and had also been shot multiple times
and buried on this motherfucker's
property
now interestingly when they started
questioning him
further
uh they discovered that this [ __ ] had
been [ __ ] killing people starting
like 2013 or 2003 rather
november of 2003
um
four people
shot to death in a uh motorcycle shop
like motorbike shop
and all four are
like worked in the shop and were shot
multiple times
now uh todd confessed to these crimes
and like after they arrested him he's
like yeah i did that [ __ ] so he just
shot four people in this [ __ ]
but i don't even know if it's a robbery
he's just like walking there like [ __ ]
shopping
so they started going through
his
[ __ ]
you know history and everything like
that he's like yeah i've killed like a
bunch more people
um
[Music]
and uh you guys haven't found them yet
and this is where the internet
connection comes in because it turns out
that when they started investigating
this [ __ ] because like i said
they didn't find him until 2016 and he's
killed i don't even know how many people
um
although he seems to be like forthcoming
with with the [ __ ]
they started going through all his uh
stuff and started like investigating his
background
and about the same time that he bought
the property like where they found some
of the bodies
there was an amazon user just known as
quote unquote me
who was posting all of these product
reviews
for stuff that he had bought off amazon
and uh this they found out obviously
that this account was linked to him like
uh todd kohlhepp
and some of his reviews
say this is one of them
haven't stabbed anyone yet yet
but i am keeping the dream alive
and when i do
it will be with a quality tool like this
this was a review for a pocket knife
that was posted in september of 2014.
keep in the car for when you have to
hide the bodies and you left the
full-size shovel at home
does not come with a [ __ ] which would
have been nice
this was another review that he wrote
for a shovel
um
so
on amazon need it you need a [ __ ] when
you have a shovel i guess because it's
[ __ ] size okay so he wanted a [ __ ]
okay to have them to wield the [ __ ]
size shovel i'm assuming that he wants
to get caught
i mean well it took a long time now yeah
they didn't catch until 2016. and he'd
apparently been killing people since at
least 2003 because they found like all
and he's like oh yeah i did this that
and the other thing too damn what the
[ __ ] man yeah
uh also he had bought a chainsaw off
amazon and the review says getting the
neighbor to stand still while you chase
him with it is hard enough without
having an easy to use chainsaw did he do
that which
funny but
i don't know well that's just his name
they don't know because there's a lot of
like other crimes that maybe he did
because they found like a lot of bodies
like on his property and he was like oh
by the way like yeah i did all these
other [ __ ] they don't know how many
people he's [ __ ] killed um there were
also some other things they said they
also found some other like not murdery
stuff like on amazon that he had
reviewed which they thought was
interesting
um
these uh also included dog toys
he didn't kill anybody with those
presumably uh some electronics and some
music stuff and uh interestingly dvds of
the walking dead yeah you like that
series i guess yeah what do you say
about the walk of death i don't know i'm
just saying they found some other
reviews but he reviewed stuff on amazon
4 sucks
i'm sure yeah can you imagine yeah i
just like this i just found this today
because it's like this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like he didn't find his victims on the
internet but apparently he thought it
was hilarious
to review products that he'd used to
actually kill people
on amazon and like when amazon figured
it out because like i said they have
zillions of [ __ ] reviews every day so
they can't like monitor everything but
when they like found that they did pull
some of them down
but here's another [ __ ] up thing so
kyla brown who they did find alive like
her boyfriend got shot and killed
but they did find her like chained up
yeah she was in a metal storage
container you were right about that yeah
um i remember that and he had reviewed
the padlocks
like i guess he bought the padlocks on
amazon and he reviewed the padlocks that
he used to like keep her in the metal
storage container he says
solid locks
have five on a shipping container won't
stop them but sure we'll slow them down
until they're too old to care
that's what he said like on the roof
yeah yeah he shot he shot that girl's
boyfriend in front of her before he
locked her in there
yeah that's good
[ __ ] oh
now hold on one second let me talk about
let me talk about mike bear
he's [ __ ] talking about eddie murphy
movies he's trying to get a rise out of
me
saying the vampire in brooklyn wasn't
any good and then he'll i i'm glad that
you liked it but i eat
vampire brooklyn was good i mean that
was very much in the spirit of the
original dracula and blacula and screen
black of the screen the tone was perfect
you know it's just it's it was just that
kind of vampire movie
you know i don't know what kind of
vampire movie you were looking for but
it was just a good mixture of romance
and [ __ ]
comedy
and
um
vampire action it was just it was just
you know
it was what it was but i liked vampire
in brooklyn i [ __ ] thought it was
great
that was great it was just and nothing
is i saw that [ __ ]
in the theater when it came out i was in
boston when that came out and it was a
movie of his time
and eddie murphy's career was not in a
good position when that came out he was
on a decline
but i still and i was in the theater by
myself it was [ __ ] dead but that
movie was great it was a great movie
just that
the time had changed you know what i
mean he was
old hat at that point
and so it's time he made a comeback you
know
if you ask me [ __ ] with the
some of the new movies that he came out
with [ __ ] uh dolomite and everything
when when dolomite came out i was like
oh eddie murphy's back i was missing him
you know so i don't you know you say
it's a shitty movie whatever [ __ ]
i also like i also like golden child
he had some really good movies really
good low budget movies we're not talking
about citizen kane it's just
entertainment you know
entertainment
okay so
let me see where was i all right so yeah
the paddle i'm entertaining them
i'm interrupting the [ __ ] show to
talk about
eddie murphy well so look we've
we've done three whole shows worth it
yeah
i'm fighting for andy murphy's honor
they already covered all that who's
fighting it freddie burbank
is great and he was great yeah he still
is great
he's great
yeah um
camp guy says see the phil chalmers
youtube channel for about an hour and a
half interview with uh cole hep very
recent yeah i need to watch that because
this [ __ ] they don't they
actually like i said they don't know how
many people he's killed because he did
admit to more but they don't uh actually
know
you know how many it was he did
eventually get charged with seven counts
of murder two counts of kidnapping
three counts of possessing murder
weapons
and uh in 2017 he was given seven
consecutive
life sentences so he will not be getting
parole he's locked up for life which is
good but
how [ __ ] up is that yeah that's the
[ __ ] like look i can see
it's [ __ ] up but like i can see like
you leaving a review on amazon for some
[ __ ] yeah i murdered some like to be
funny
but
it's not funny when you actually do it
it's like not a joke anymore so
yeah yeah mike see that [ __ ] again man
it was a good movie it's a good movie dj
maniac said it he slept on it forever
saw it and it was great it's so much
better than the [ __ ] they make today
i don't like to sound like an old
[ __ ] coming out like oh back in
our day but no it's just a straight
vampire kind of comedy romance
horror type movie it's
for the mainstream it's a mainstream
type move
you know
i i you'll you'll have fun with it it's
just a fun movie you got the recipe
all right let's do one more
and this is like fairly brief
so we're going to talk about
hiroshi
may okay
he's known as the suicide website
murderer
now this guy
okay so he's from osaka
uh japan
now his whole thing
was that when he got older he had like a
sexual proclivity
toward
seeing people in distress particularly
when they were uh strangling to death
so
um
yeah
what he would do at first
he tried to like well i don't know he
necessarily tried to murder people but
he did actually like try to strangle
people just to like get that like sexual
charge for time like without necessarily
trying to kill them that's how he
started out
so he was a student um and he tried to
strangle
a male friend of his
now this friend lived
um
but i guess he kind of got a taste for
it right so he drops out of college in
1988 hiroshi did
1995 he apparently tries to like state
this weird uh
proclivity that he has
uh he had beat up one of his co-workers
and tried to strangle him because like i
said he had a thing where he got off on
seeing people be strangled
now uh the case actually he got arrested
but the case got settled out of court um
he got fired obviously but they didn't
put him in prison
which maybe they should have in
hindsight but what are you gonna do this
was japan
2001
he tries to strangle two women
now at this point they didn't die
but he did get arrested and he got
sentenced to
a year in prison and then a three-year
suspended sentence
while he was in prison he was apparently
a very good behavior model prisoner
so he got an early release
now at this point he hadn't killed
anybody yet
i mean it's heading up to it obviously
but he hadn't killed anybody yet to this
point but he does have a thing for
people getting strangled
so then he's uh back out free
so at this point he
uh
you know
kind of like finds a kid
a young junior high school kid who was i
believe only 14 years old
and he tries to strangle
that kid
now he gets arrested for that
and he got another year and 10 months in
prison again he didn't kill the kid but
it was just he tried to strangle us
so he got let out again in 2005.
now at this point
it's kind of like
i don't know i kind of feel like this is
obviously a pattern
so maybe somebody should intervene
but
you know what do i know
so he's like trying to like suffocate
people
he hasn't killed anybody they've been
putting him in jail for like a year or
two here or there
and then letting him back out
so
he decides what he learns from all this
from being put in prison all these times
it's like well
from now on then
i should just make sure i kill the
people so they can't report me to the
police
yeah that's what serial rapists do sure
that's what he was thinking of
now interestingly japan
is a very interesting culture because
they do they have very very few murders
but they have very very very high uh
suicide rate
because um i guess
i guess there's a lot of factors but i
guess because
um you know their culture is very like
uh you know work oriented it's very
uh you know uh result oriented like if
you're not living up to it's very shame
oriented like if you're not really
living up to what you think you're
supposed to be living up to you're like
causing shame to everyone and you feel
like you're not worth anything so
you need to kill yourself so there's a
lot of that going on so they have a very
very high suicide rate
and uh they also have weirdly
a bunch of websites in japan like
suicide clubs
where people go on there and like
commiserate about
wanting to kill themselves which
okay
but then they kind of like try to like
hook up and be like okay well we're
gonna kill ourselves together you know
to like do suicide pact type of stuff
so there's that
so this is again where the internet
comes into this uh particular case
now one of the main
causes of suicide at least at this time
i don't know about nowadays
but what they would do is they would put
and i don't even what is this
it's called an antique charcoal burner
they put it in the car
and then they like asphyxiate themselves
in the car
charcoal burner there must be some of
those little damn brown things you put
charcoal that's what i thought
a little three and then like you die
from the fumes yeah but you cook on it i
mean so i kind of feel like well why
don't you just do carbon monoxide then
because people in the u.s do carbon
monoxide like you shut yourself in the
garage and like put the thing in the
tailpipe and the hose into the you put
the hose in the tailpipe and then put
and you know i'm not a banana in the
tailpipe
don't do that i'm just saying that like
some people in the us do that
like close themselves up but you know
what i mean like because you'll die from
carbon monoxide and apparently i don't
know but apparently people say it's like
a pretty peaceful death you just kind of
like fall asleep like from the gas
but so there's that but i don't but i
don't know so antique charcoal burner
i'm not really sure what that is but
they put that in the car
and apparently that was like all the
rage for if you were killing yourself
like back in
uh back in the 2000s mid-2000s when this
was going on
so what this [ __ ] would do
uh meue
is he would either
like start a threat or he would start
like a you know community or whatever
of like a suicide club and he's like
look yeah i want to kill myself too
we're going to like get together and
we're going to like have a suicide pact
we're going to die together so that's
what he would do so that's how he would
like lure people
uh so he started like frequenting these
suicide pacts like discussion boards and
websites and stuff like that
and then he would like agree to meet
with them
and he would say yeah i'm gonna kill
myself too and
we'll die together it'll be it'll be
fine
so his first victim
sadly was a 14 year old boy uh who he
had met on an online suicide forum this
little kid was apparently having
a time and uh wanted to end it
so he started talking to this guy online
and he's like yeah i'll kill myself with
you
and so he goes and picks the kid up
and
what usually ends up happening in these
in his cases are that
you know he'll pick the person up and
say hey we're going to die together
and then the person will kind of like
when it actually becomes real
they'll like change their mind a little
bit i don't know if i want to go through
with this and then he'll like just reach
over and like manually strangle them
which because like i said he gets off on
strangling people he gets off on like
seeing their face like when they are in
agony and they know that they're gonna
die like that's kind of his thing so
so the first person he killed was a 14
year old boy that he met an online
suicide forum
his second victim was a 25 year old
woman named michiko nakamoto
and she was killed in a similar fashion
in 2005. again he met her online on a
suicide forum
and um
you know they were in the car together
he had picked her up from somewhere and
then they were going to go someplace and
supposedly both kill themselves and then
she seemed to have second thoughts she's
like i don't know if i want to go
through with this or not and then he
basically tied her up and then um
smothered her is what he did
and uh one of the quotes uh when they
asked him about it later was he said i
wanted to watch a face in agony so that
was uh yeah he got sexual pleasure from
watching other people's faces when they
were dying or like in pain
his third victim was a 21 year old man a
similar situation who he had met on a
suicide form and picked up and then
strangled them and he buried all of his
victims in the mountains
uh so yeah that's basically what he
would do he would just say yeah i want
to kill myself too we're going to do
this together
and
obviously he had no intention of killing
himself and even if the person had
second thoughts about it uh he was like
not going to let that happen he would
just usually like
end up strangling them
and that's uh what would happen he said
later when they caught him
uh was that
strangling someone with his bare hands
was the only way that he could get
sexual pleasure
and he also said
that the people that he killed uh four
of them that they know of
he would uh he said that he'd filmed all
the murders because he wanted to watch
them later so he could get off on them
again
so you know
um and basically when they finally
caught this [ __ ]
that was his excuse i don't know if it
was so much an excuse he knew it was bad
but he said look this is the only way
that i can get my rocks off yeah it's
like strangling people yeah
and obviously
this man's need to come is more
important than other people being live
yeah yeah so
hey i just had to come you know you know
how it is
it sounds like bbck instead of like some
btk for a second yeah yeah wow you know
how yeah yeah
can you imagine can you imagine
thinking that your orgasm
is more important than like random
people's lives sexual problems i can't
imagine what that must be like to be
that narcissistic
i really can't though no i do that's
[ __ ] crazy
uh but yeah
so
they called it um
he said okay so when they finally caught
him he said oh i read this mystery novel
when i was a kid
and it had a whole thing about like
strangling or something like that and he
super got off on it
and after that he was like obsessed with
like strangling people
and uh so they said his defense said
that he was uh had paraphilic
psychosexual disorder and you know in
other words the only way to get off is
by doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] in his case
strangling people
so uh basically the prosecutor was not
having it it's like look we don't care
if you have that um but obviously you're
getting your rocks off is not more
important than like other people's lives
so probably you should be taken off the
streets yeah because probably
if we let you out you're gonna do this
[ __ ] again
um you know
it's like he killed uh three people in
like a four-month span so like that's
just gonna escalate
so probably not the best day yet
so uh at this point 2007
the district court in osaka
uh agreed with the prosecution and said
yeah we should kill this [ __ ]
and honestly like from what i've heard i
don't know if this is true or not but um
from what i've heard
uh he actually the killer actually said
himself
that i should be put to death because if
i am let out ever
uh then i can't guarantee that i won't
do it again essentially
because i can't he's like i'm not really
sure of myself i would probably do it
again
uh so he's like so please kill me i
don't know if that's true or not but i
have heard that from some sources that
he actually asked for the death penalty
so um but they did give it to him
whether he wanted it or not
and i didn't really realize this but in
2007 they were still hanging people in
japan
they hung him
or hanged him
so they hanged him in 2007 because he
basically said look i can't i can't
promise that i'm not gonna [ __ ] kill
more people
so at least he knew that about himself i
suppose that's that's one nice thing
so yeah he got hanged in uh july of 2009
so he's [ __ ] dead that's one less
person we have to worry about
so there's that oh well oh well what are
you gonna do
so that's the show
i can't believe we got through all the
stuff and i was still like fairly
coherent yeah yeah we're both go here
you want some toast cheat
you want some toast cheese yeah i need
some toast are you gonna talk while i'm
chewing or is not or is it gonna be
weird
or is everybody gonna like listen to me
chewing
you're all open all over them i'll open
them up for you we'll share them
i don't know if you guys understand the
[ __ ] glorious [ __ ]
we don't have any we don't have any more
captains wafers of what captains wafers
the sour cream and chives no no we don't
have any more of those no i bought some
and he bought something that were out i
guess oh [ __ ]
what's everybody saying
well i don't know i'm just like waiting
for a cracker there you go i've been
talking toshi
i know it's a toasty
cracker with cheese filling
well wait a minute which one's like
there's some that are cheese cracker
with peanut butter in there yeah i don't
have them oh okay what are those called
toachy peanut butter
hmm
i thought they had a different name no
john goris points something out he
choked he combed he died
yeah when he when they hanged him
oh maybe that was one of the reasons he
wanted to be hanged he thought they'd be
like the ultimate orgasm i wonder did he
like [ __ ]
shoot a wad like when he [ __ ]
probably not it's probably never as good
as i think it's gonna be
well nothing ever is but i'm just saying
i wonder if he was like kind of jazzed
about it he was like really into
strangling other people yeah
i don't know i kind of feel like that
kind of person
not always
because btk kind of had a little bit of
a i want to be the victim kind of thing
too but a lot of serial killers have
that whole like power trip
they like inflicting pain on other
people and they get off on watching
other people suffering but when you make
them suffer they're the first ones like
start crying you know what i mean
so
i don't know i don't know which type of
dude this this dude was there's not
actually a lot of information about that
guy in english yeah uh because he was
japanese but i did find like a couple of
little things about him but i thought
i'd mention it because of the michael
clark wants to know if there's any more
impressions because he loves dennis
yeah there's other impressions
there's other impressions there's
[ __ ] steven seagal i do see this
again
what else do i do that's always fun yeah
somebody said earlier that steven seagal
should play uh james bond yeah yeah
that'd be fun
they should oh you know what okay look i
want you to know
somebody okay asylum yeah if somebody in
asylum is listening right now yeah
do a whole direct-to-dvd james bond
series all the james bond movies like
but knock-offs like change one word in
the title or something but put steven
seagal in the james bond role in every
single movie let's see how that goes
we'd go like a [ __ ] fart in a space
suit i would watch it yeah
i would watch it i'd have to be like
pretty inebriated to watch it but it
would probably be super hilarious god
man it's so early it's so late in the
show i'm so [ __ ] loaded and you guys
want to bring up [ __ ] cigar
look i gotta say
told this [ __ ] i've told this story many
times
but i actually like steven seagal's
stomach some of stephen segal's movies
his early ones
under siege one and under siege two were
pretty good
um
hard to kill was good
alfred i think was out for justice i
think that one was pretty good i
remember because i think it's called out
for justice i love the generic names
yeah yeah
yeah you could have a [ __ ] ai
computer if i could write those names
they probably have you have you ever
seen those like poem magnets like that
are like just a bunch of random words
and you can put them on your fridge and
like rearrange them and [ __ ] yeah they
have that
hard cut hard kill
that's what i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] steal justice you know okay
like that you're like okay yeah that's
it
but granite justice yeah
but over the years if you've been
listeners to the show you'd understand
that uh i'm [ __ ] fascinated with the
enigma that is stevens ago
even though i think i've solved the
enigma he's just yeah there's there's no
enigma or no real neglect
but what
what fascinates me is that
he fooled me in my whole [ __ ] army
unit
in the 506. we thought he was actually
like something yeah like a [ __ ] navy
seal everybody nothing yeah
yeah you just kind of had to be there at
the time
but uh
seagal had many special attributes like
you know
he could change his accent to be any
ethnic group
he could be black he could be italian
he could be
a [ __ ] chinese he could be japanese
he could do every
[ __ ]
accent you could ever think of just
depending on who it was he was talking
to and what question you asked him
i saw him
he would go on [ __ ]
talk shows and they'd ask him a [ __ ]
question
about
about his training back in japan and he
would immediately start reverting into a
japanese accent or an asian and asian
accent
and what's funny is like
the interviewers would be like [ __ ] i
don't know david letterman or whatever
you could go back and see them they're
on they're on youtube you can
you can see that the interviewers know
he's full of [ __ ] they're asking him
[ __ ] stupid ass questions they know
he's full of [ __ ]
and a lot of the audience are kind of
like halfway buying into the crap that
he's talking about
and uh
you just
okay [ __ ]
the main question is this is
is steven seagal a martial artist and
the answer is yeah he is a martial
artist he uh
and he was uh
he was good at his martial art i think
it was aikido
the problem was is that aikido was not a
[ __ ] real martial art it's more
defensive it's more of a yeah it's not
really a fighting
yeah and it was a defensive [ __ ]
skill
that maybe would have been relevant back
in the tokugawa period of japan
when you were a peasant and you were
being attacked by a samurai who had a
sword
then maybe akito would have meant
something
but it would have only meant something
in japan back in those days
back in the day when
even a samurai was kind of a wallflower
kind of a nerdy dude who learned his
training out of a book
some people might be like well what the
[ __ ]
have you ever lived in the middle east i
lived in korea
for for a year
korea it's not the middle east let me
see my middle is i mean
well if you live in the far east
uh you'll you'll understand
east asian cultures are very
kind of cookie cutter and
ritualistic uh they're real um
oriented towards what school you went to
and what your degrees and your diplomas
were and everything is very cookie
cutter
they have a very small
um overton window of acceptability of
things and
um
like when i was in korea even katusas
and rock army guys they might be [ __ ]
fourth or fifth level [ __ ] taekwondo
masters you could kick their asses
just with ghetto fighting
they're very much by the book and very
ritualized everything is standardized
cookie cutter
so aikido maybe would have worked
against the cookie cutter samurai
uh
well somebody that just wasn't gonna
like start jumping on your head and wail
on right somebody who wasn't [ __ ]
now if you look at
guys who are real
sword masters
like musashi
if you look at [ __ ] shimon musashi
the way he grew up
he was ghetto basically his dad was a
swords master he was he owned his own
school and [ __ ]
musashi was [ __ ] lived hard he lived
he slept outside on the run he was a
[ __ ] wanted felon
at certain times of his
[ __ ] life
a mercenary who was joining armies he
would join an army knowing that army
would lose and just to polish his skills
and uh ended up writing books okay
musashi was [ __ ] hardcore but he
would
kill dudes he was a psychopath all right
and would fight
three or four guys you know
they weren't as good as him but
a lot of when you really analyze what
he's talking about a lot of what musashi
was talking about was genetics
he was bigger and stronger than them uh
tougher meaner
and used a lot of psychological warfare
and musashi and his day would have been
like somebody from [ __ ] the hood
all right that's that's really why you
won
and that kind of stands to today you
have a big [ __ ] who takes a lot
of ruins and is mean and
from the hood grew up fighting against
his [ __ ] brothers his older brothers
and was always getting beat on and
beating other dudes they don't have to
[ __ ] go to all this training and [ __ ]
they just grow up tough
knowing how to fight and that's kind of
how
she was i kind of feel like part of
being tough is part of getting your ass
back all the time and like being able to
take it yeah they get to have like more
endurance exactly than the other person
they get their asses beat all the time
and then [ __ ] go i gotta win i gotta
win and they rise up from the ass
beatings and become the ass beater
all right that's that's that's and
that's the way musashi was
you couldn't learn that from a book it's
lifestyle
yeah you kind of have to endure that
yeah
yeah and musashi didn't care if he lived
or died he was like a kamikaze
and because of that attitude people were
afraid to fight him and he went through
[ __ ] hundreds of challenges and came
out on top of the best swordsman's that
japan had to offer
in his time
but the best swordsman in japan had to
offer in his time were upper middle
class to upper class guys who had a lot
of money and a lot to lose they didn't
want to get killed
psychology has a lot to do with it
but uh you can you can um listen to some
of his books they're still around
on um
youtube uh you can get it on audiobook
you can listen to it it was called um
um hagakuri i think because
they were [ __ ] hidden behind leaves i
think is within no no no
uh
the book of the five rings that's the
one you want yeah nicholas lomando said
i have his look at the fire breeze
hardcover bound and silver book of the
fire the five rings look at the five
rings that's what you said the thing is
that sounds nice actually a lot of them
you should show a picture of that yeah
a lot of the book of the five rings is
kind of censored
though
okay at least the audio books are
uh some of the [ __ ] [ __ ] the advice
that [ __ ]
musashi will give you will [ __ ] lead
you down a bad path like it says
get yourself incarcerated
commit murders
i mean get incarcerated and learn to
free yourself by your own wits
[ __ ] you know i'm not judging your
life choices yeah i'm just saying i
don't know if that's the best
use of it he says things like [ __ ] go
where other men
fear to tread place where criminals and
gangsters and murderers go and learn to
dominate in those areas
all great advice that is exactly
the way of the warrior
and even we have a [ __ ] federal agent
in here that i grew up with named
grafters grabbed us he will tell you
because he went in places where
criminals tread to go fight them and
that was the same same thing musashi was
doing all right you don't go hang out
with [ __ ] good people to become a
badass you hang out with bad people to
become a badass
and he would just kind of rise above it
he was a mercenary
though a criminal and a mercenary
um which don't confuse the two there's a
different state of criminal in a
mercenary even though sometimes there's
some overlap but
mercenaries are not bad people have
known many of them and served with many
mercenaries a mercenary is just a guy
who is serving for a country that is not
his own you're still getting paid by
your client though you're just a
professional soldier
so i know that hollywood kind of
portrays that as as something bad it
isn't
a mercenaries help to the creation of
the united states uh like thaddeus
cuscusco who was a mercenary from poland
and he was he was a [ __ ] very
honorable man
and uh helped the united states become
an independent country
and he was this little [ __ ]
poetry reading little [ __ ] officer
who was real good at organizing and
training
armies and uh
[ __ ] um liked what america had to
offer and he liked the american um
character
and he didn't like european
um empires and the way they dominated
other countries
thaddeus was a very good man and um kind
of like lord byron he was a little bitty
publisher reading [ __ ] so when
you say mercenary you're thinking of the
hollywood
the hollywood interpretation of what a
mercenary is a big old [ __ ] criminal
who beat up the weak and [ __ ] no that's
that's not what it what it means
it's somebody a professional soldier
that you hire to help you
that's what it is
but uh
yeah that's all i'm gonna say about that
what are they saying in there
michael clark says jean-claude van damme
i heard wanted to fight seagal at a
party at sylvester stallone's house yeah
yeah that would have been awesome i was
going to say that would they should make
a movie about that yeah i would watch
that it's my understanding
it is my understanding so what happened
tom it is my understanding i don't
follow the celebrity gossip yeah
i have followed it
it's my understanding that steven seagal
ran from every [ __ ] challenge
i mean that's kind of the impression
yeah too well because
like i was saying earlier anybody that's
out there like showing off about how
awesome they are i'm such a badass i'm a
navy seal i'm this that another if you
gotta like tell people about that [ __ ]
then you're probably like the world's
biggest [ __ ] and like the second
somebody calls you out on it you're
gonna like [ __ ] run
between your legs because you don't you
can't back it up you're all mouth it was
another time he's all mouth
me and graham grew up in this time it
was another time it was a time when
black belt magazine was still on the
[ __ ] shelves of the [ __ ] magazine
is it still no not anymore it's gone it
was still on the shelves at [ __ ]
7-eleven where you could see photographs
of dudes jumping through the air [ __ ]
busting through boards you weren't sure
what was true and what wasn't true
you know about martial arts i kind of
feel like the bruce lee mystique was
still it was still in there that is
video games like [ __ ] shinobi and
[ __ ] we're still around all of them
you weren't sure what was true there was
still kind of like this magical thinking
when it came to fighting especially with
eastern martial arts and it still exists
in china china still believes in that
[ __ ] and the mma chinese mma
fighters will beat the [ __ ] out of these
kung fu masters and everybody gets mad
at the [ __ ] mma guy
what happened was eventually a [ __ ]
um
ultimate fighting came out which is the
predecessor it was that was the
precursor to
to um
mma
and uh that came out
which was like real wrestling and
fighting and cage matches and [ __ ] we
thought that was some criminal [ __ ] and
then eventually mma came out mma is real
fighting
i mean that's just like use whatever
you need to use as long as you're not
[ __ ] murdering the dude but
you know but that's it mma it's gonna
end up on the ground almost like a
wrestling match with kickboxing and
punching and all that [ __ ] mixing
together kicking and punching and
wrestling
that is actually
mma is what bruce lee was talking about
if you see his interviews that you have
to go outside these eastern styles and
find a real fighting style that actually
works
that you know and that you could do it
in an arena and that and people can see
it and uh that it's legal he was talking
about mma
and i've done a lot of study and
analysis and
i've listened to the experts on
kung fu and karate and [ __ ] all the
eastern martial arts and the mma guys
and come to the conclusion that
bruce lee would have been pretty good in
mma
even though he was an actor and he did
it was chinese theater that he was doing
he was still good
i mean he was still in like really good
shape yeah he'd have been good
most people think that he probably would
have [ __ ] done some weight training
and got on [ __ ] performance-enhancing
drugs
and gained about 15 to 20 pounds and
learned a ground game and got into
[ __ ] mma and got it done pretty good
but
he couldn't do that for a living though
you know he was an actor
he had to make movies
he was just born in his in his time
uh he wasn't superhuman though
he was just
he was a fighter of his time and an
actor
still i you know i respect bruce lee he
he envisioned
mma
well and he was a pioneer in a lot of
ways i mean he
in a way he was like really
responsible for popularizing
um martial arts movies in the west yeah
which
had been very very niche prior to that
so the fact that everybody saw that [ __ ]
like when bruce lee was in them that was
like something what i liked about him is
he had a spiritual element yeah he had a
spiritual element and he was big into
self-development and
challenging the self
which is uh yeah
special operations and everything and
infantry guys
and law enforcement guys know exactly
what that's what he's talking about
yeah he was right
he was right he was just a man of his
times he was envisioning a better time
which eventually did arrive
he just mma sadly was not here to see it
yeah
died by an accident and his son too
weird weird that accidents got him right
that is very weird yeah
i mean
i don't think there's any conspiracy in
it but
uh bad i don't think so either it's just
a [ __ ]
just [ __ ] which is one of those
things that's one of those things it's
just sad because he was like in such
[ __ ] really good shape and then
he just like
some kind of weird ash i don't think
anybody murdered him or nothing like
that but
he basically just took what like aspirin
or ibuprofen or something like that got
into a fight and a blood clot got him if
i remember correctly
wasn't it
um i think it was it was injury related
if i remember
no i thought it was just like he took
some aspirin or something like for a
headache and then he's just
maybe you're thinking of harry houdini
who got punched in the stomach and then
he died later on
i think it was still fight related
somehow i don't know it might have been
yeah i don't really remember
uh michael clark said question is there
a difference between brazilian jiu-jitsu
and the other styles of
jiu jitsu or is it all the same
i'm not sure i'm not an expert in jiu
jitsu
but the gracies you know in brazil came
up with that
and it was just like supposed to be a
synthesis of a bunch of stuff that
worked and it was
basically kind of like something you
could use in mma
that's my understanding of it
i i don't know the differences between
the different versions of jiu jitsu
but you
know i'm not the guy to ask about that
john gore says the epic rap battle of
history with bruce lee versus clint
eastwood is a classic i didn't see it i
don't think i've seen that one i've seen
some of the other ones but i don't think
i've seen that one yeah uh hugo said i
like bruce lee in the green hornet yeah
he was cool in that yeah
honestly i've seen all the bruce lee
movies
he didn't make that many
three what was it three and a half
something i don't think i've ever seen
him you've never seen them no i don't
think i've ever seen him
we need to rectify that situation holy
crap
i thought you'd like to like [ __ ]
kung fu boys and stuff
the only the only movie i've ever seen
that had bruce lee in it was the one
that was made uh
after he died game of death game of
death which they made like he'd shot
some of it and then he died and then
like they kind of like made a movie
around him i've only seen game of death
okay well that's like the worst one yeah
it's what they said but i i enjoyed it
no it's still like a decent movie yeah i
don't mind that movie i'm just saying
that's like the other ones that like had
crammed abdul jabbar in it the other
ones are better left a big [ __ ]
footprint on him when he kicked him
you haven't even seen enter the dragon
no i've never seen it where the [ __ ]
have you been
i've just seen interviews with him enter
the dragon is so good yeah i love it
another dragon
but you know what i mean
um
[Music]
yeah they're talking about
chuck norris gave bruce some aspirin
yeah maybe chuck norris but ooh let's
start that conspiracy theory did
somebody already start that huh the
chuck norris like poisoned bruce lee
[Laughter]
i don't like i said i've never heard
that but it's like if we want us do we
want to start that conspiracy theory
because we could we're starting to like
right here mike's saying right now
[ __ ]
especially cigar was never in the
universal soldier
oh [ __ ]
damn aspirin or whatever that is but um
yeah universal soldier was a good movie
i was in service when that came out we
went we all went down to go see it was
101st a lot of guys had to go see it
they had the [ __ ] dab desert camo
chuckle chip camo on at the time the
[ __ ]
didn't when he wearing little eye pieces
and let and lasers and [ __ ]
what are you asking me for i don't know
yeah i wasn't there we liked that movie
it's pretty good
weirdest thing about [ __ ] van damme
is that that [ __ ] was always trying to
get naked on [ __ ] camera
trying to show us to see that stephen oh
he's trying to show ass no one wants to
see everybody and the dudes weren't
seeing these movies you know women
weren't seeing these movie dudes were
and we were like look at this [ __ ]
and he was like coming out with photos
of himself nude [ __ ] cradling [ __ ]
cheetah cubs and [ __ ] there's just i
don't know what that dude's looking for
we'll see some european [ __ ]
i don't even think it's european i think
there was like a lot of latent
gay [ __ ] like going on with especially
like a lot of the action movies in the
80s i mean now we see it now it's very
obvious
but back then everybody was just like
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's like so masculine
but like now we're watching it being
like they weren't thinking that though
okay we saw that [ __ ] back there were
like cigars [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
some european [ __ ] what's he doing what
are you doing
no one wants to see your butt
crazy says jack nance died in a similar
fashion after a bar fight that's right
the actor in the david lynch movies yeah
he was in a racer head he was in twin
peaks he was a lot of david lynch yeah
yeah that's right i forgot about that
yeah a few days later he had think had a
blood clot yeah that can happen mike's
[ __ ] about never seen an end of the
dragon i've never seen it i can't
believe you've never seen i've seen
enter the dragon at least 20 times well
maybe i've seen it and and don't
remember it you might not i have to see
it again
that's it but it's good that [ __ ] comes
up and i don't want to click it because
i don't want to make jenny mad because i
figured she probably i didn't want to
see that
but not uh i've seen it though lately
i've been getting all lately i've been
getting off into um
into a [ __ ] oh what's his name we saw
malone last night [ __ ] burt reynolds
reynolds yeah reynolds is actually and
his very obvious hairpiece yeah very
obvious hairpiece it's still a good
movie though yeah but like i was like
watching the movie being like oh look i
can see the line where the hair piece
and the real hair like intersect yeah
white light in hd white lightning was
good
gator was good which is the second part
of that and malone was good he played a
cia assassin who was kind of like he
didn't want to do it anymore but it was
good flick
and um
yeah and then we've also been seeing um
other movies like [ __ ] uh what's his
name
oh um
[ __ ]
what are you talking about
that other dude
thanks that's that's yeah that other guy
yeah i'm getting a guy with the head and
the head and ours you know [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the guy from [ __ ] death wish [ __ ]
what's his name charles brown charles
bronze i've been watching charles
bronson movies
we still need to see 10 to midnight yeah
although it's there for free i know
although i do kind of feel like i do
want to see that because i've seen that
and it is yeah i've seen that before and
it's actually really good you probably
really like charles bronson is pretty
good but so far i liked the uh
uh the mechanic
although i will say that like on the
matinees at some point i would really
like to get back to the horror and
sci-fi we can do it
i mean i know like i i like action
movies too but i'm just kind of like er
and the 80s movies but yeah michael
clark says question for jenny can you
recommend a netflix night to watch
realistic but well done serial killer
movies ooh
john coming out with sharks
sharky's machine i remember that
yeah i remember that one shark there's a
he said there's a falling stunt in there
i remember sharky's machine i got to see
that one again too
there were there were a lot of burt
reynolds movies that kind of came and
went when i was young and i never really
got to see him
uh but they're better than i thought
they were
they're pretty good
i'm trying to think i haven't looked on
netflix in a while so i don't actually
know what's on there yeah
um
let me see
i'm trying to think of like some
realistic like serial killer movies
like ones that are based on actual
serial killers are ones that are like
fictionalized serial killers
because honestly if you haven't seen
zodiac the michael fincher one or the
david fincher one um you need to see
that because that's awesome
um
[Music]
there was one
about jeffrey dahmer like my friend
dahmer is good but that's not really a
horror movie but there was one that was
just called dahmer
that was actually pretty decent i don't
know if it's on netflix or it might be
on another streaming service but that
was actually pretty good
um
i'm trying to think of like what there
was oh there was another one there was
another one
what am i thinking of
if you want once like a fake serial
killer um i'm kind of a big fan of the
collector series
i think i don't know if those are on
netflix or they might be on
shutter
they're on one of the streaming services
because i've i watched them recently
there's two or three of them i can't
remember
the collector there's the collection
and then i don't know if there's a third
one tammy says watch lawless on two
beats tom hardy plays a re plays a
moonshiner oh [ __ ] that sounds good
i'm gonna have to look at it okay
remember look at that
yeah henry portrait of a serial killer
obviously that's a good one with michael
rooker
uh yeah based on
uh you know henry lee lucas and otis
toole yeah
they're bullshitting asses yeah although
i mean i forgot how like um old that
movie was we reviewed it a while back
and
it's not as it's disturbing but it's not
as disturbing as it was back in the old
days because i kind of feel like
everybody was like [ __ ] freaking out
about it back when it came out
um
gotta say though
henry lee lucas
[ __ ] yeah i don't think he killed as
many people i do think he killed people
i'm not saying that he is he is a
scumbag
but
i think he probably killed three or four
people max i don't know
i don't think he killed all the people
he said he killed some people during
those robberies and he killed i think
his mom was it
yeah he yeah mom and his grandma or
something he did kill people he did kill
a few people yeah but he wasn't a serial
he's not a good person but i don't think
that he was going around because i do
kind of feel like once he was in prison
yeah there's an actually there's a
documentary about it i think it's er it
was on netflix because i watched it on
there i don't know if it's on there
still use a confession machine but there
i can't remember what it's called but
it's about henry lucas
and it's about
how
he would basically just confess to
anything because they would like let him
like come out and talk to people and
like they would give him like milkshakes
and like burgers and [ __ ] because they
were trying to like get him to confess
to [ __ ] oh yeah yeah i killed that one
too in in omaha or wherever the [ __ ]
he didn't do that yeah he didn't do that
no he was like confessing to all kind of
unsolved [ __ ] all right let's go ahead
and shut down jen i'm hungry about you i
got food that will heat up what you got
uh
you want some more of that uh chickpea
stuff you're gonna make something else
up i don't know that chickpeas stuff
it's pretty good it's ready to go i
could i could hate i couldn't eat i got
chickpea curry down here you mean
chickpea curry is good yeah very good
it's good we made like [ __ ] time after
time was a good jack the ripper movie
yeah we've talked about it many times i
gotta get that [ __ ] on blu-ray
yeah 1979 if you haven't seen malcolm
mcdowell
uh david warner yeah yeah mary
steenburgen captain crazy said that we
mentioned that movie many times on the
show that was one of the first movies we
reviewed i think like in the first six
months of doing this show like for a
long time ago uh because that was one of
my favorite movies from childhood it's a
sleeper flick and honestly like seeing
it again recently i was like yep still
love it 1979 that [ __ ] came out oh it's
so good and i feel like a lot of people
don't
talk about it
yeah it's about malcolm mcdowell okay if
you haven't seen it malcolm mcdowell
plays h.g wells yeah
and he's friends well he doesn't know it
he's friends with
jack doctor played by david warner who's
actually jack the ripper but he doesn't
know this yeah now h.g wells has
actually invented the time machine that
he talked about in his fiction
and jack the ripper escapes into 1979
san francisco in the time machine yeah
and h.g wells has to follow him but it's
not as goofy as it sounds it's actually
like really really good he's gonna go
catch jack the real he has to go catch
because he feels morally obligated yeah
uh and he's in san francisco in the
[ __ ] early 80s or late 70s in the
late 70s and he's trying to be victorian
as [ __ ] these women are trying to throw
the [ __ ] cooch at him and he's like
oh free love right yes i understand all
about free love it's this is a great
movie it's great movie it's a great
movie and [ __ ] it's just so good i
love you jack the river says [ __ ]
where i come from i'm a freak but here
i'm a you know what i mean i'm a [ __ ]
master you know
with all this [ __ ]
murder and [ __ ] death and [ __ ] yeah
he fits right in yeah he says
i'm an amateur compared to these people
and you know it's a great thing to catch
up yeah yeah yeah
it's that kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah there's
like here's another one it's really
really cause you guys missed it early i
just got this [ __ ] on blu-ray ray
zardoz
all right sorry
stardust that's a good one some people
are like what kind of movie is that man
no matter sean connery and little red
paintings about the elites of the earth
have [ __ ] depopulated the planet and
they've used guys like sean connery to
depopulate them they're called the
brutals
and it's a post-apocalyptic movies great
movie ahead of his time it has one
weakness and that's the opening scene
with his dude with a stupid-ass head
who's narrating the [ __ ] story which
wasn't supposed to be in there you and
your stupid ass stupid-ass head
that scene was not supposed to be in
this movie but it made but the director
was like what are you putting this in
here because the dude
everything that dude says you find out
if you watch the [ __ ] movie you don't
need him there well i kind of feel like
back in the day people thought that
audiences were dumb yeah i mean some of
them are i'm not saying that but mostly
we're on the ball
you don't gotta explain everything the
movie is supposed to start these [ __ ]
brutal [ __ ]
sitting out there in the field like
gigantic flying stone heads come because
i am zardos and it spits up all these
[ __ ] guns and ammo and they're
picking it all up but stardust thank you
zardos [ __ ] go out go out kill people
thank you zarna you know that's
basically how the movies
and then you find out what the [ __ ] is
happening man because these [ __ ] have
been told to [ __ ] depopulate the
planet
and uh see like i said i think it would
have been a much stronger maybe if you
just started with that because everybody
would have been watching me like what
the [ __ ] is going on yeah yeah yeah you
want to know more about it yeah yeah
don't explain everything like right from
the beginning sean connery climbs inside
the head to try to figure out where the
head came from it's like there's
something up with this head why they got
us depopulating the planet yeah what is
going on and he kills the dude inside
he's wondering
the head goes back to this [ __ ] elite
place where there were the [ __ ]
people that rule the earth are just
living in these little cottages and [ __ ]
and he's trying to figure why are they
having us kill all these people and
that's that's that's why not yeah that's
what i said great flick
rebecca says conrad is mankini yeah yeah
sexy ass boots and his [ __ ] russian
revolver he said furry you got that damn
mozine the god revolver or it's a
thunderboltzing in the gun i remember
kind of it's a it's a semi-automatic
revolver you're like what the [ __ ] is
that you shoot it's british the [ __ ]
top of the revolver goes to the rear and
[ __ ] spins the cylinder and then it
goes forward again i never see anything
like it you cocked the revolver by
pulling it to the rear that was i don't
remember what kind of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
was that
that's great the gun is good the penis
is evil that's right that's right that's
what the head says
that's killing people is good
reproduction no that's bad
yeah keep that in your pants just shoot
people in the face yeah
tammy asked if we'd seen peaky blinders
i haven't yet but so many people have
recommended it that i really needed
that's another one that i really needed
to get into honestly even the bartender
at ibarr lee
told us years ago you guys need to watch
peaky blanders the name of the jhg wells
the ripper movie we're talking about was
called time after time after time 1979.
it's a great movie i love that movie i
saw that i saw that movie a million
times it was on cable
every five [ __ ] time after time i
guess it was like cheap to get it and
you can live stream it off amazon they
have it i for last i saw did they i
think they did okay i think it did i
mean i don't want to like i hate to like
hype stuff up to like people that didn't
see it when they were younger because
it's like they might seem to be like
what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] no it's
good
but i [ __ ] love them she saw and she
loved it i loved it she thought it was
great it's really really good i mean
[ __ ] hg wells jack the ripper time
machine let me see if it's serial
killing time travel you can't get wrong
i mean honestly i [ __ ] loved it
uh
let's see
yeah it's on netflix yeah about uh peaky
blinders i've been i've been meaning to
like watch that dude i haven't even like
we haven't finished rome yet i haven't
even finished midnight mass yet that's
how behind i am yes time after time is
on um
amazon
prime for 3.99 you can rent okay
yeah i kind of feel like that's what we
should own because yeah i need to get it
i love that although i have to say that
if you ask me right now i'm like i'm
kind of drunk right now but like if you
asked me when i was sober if to recite
that entire movie from memory i probably
could
because i've seen it so many times
i mean
it's imprinted
but yeah oh starry night just hit just
hit us up says are you ready for me bro
yeah i'm ready for you
we're going down to the show
they're going to be in us yeah yeah
yeah a starry night are coming here yeah
to orlando on saturday yeah so we're
obligated to go see them
we're obligated we have we're going to
go see them
we like when they come to will's pub
they haven't been here in a while but
yeah they're coming so they just
messaged us and asked if we yeah if they
were okay let's shut it down jen i'm
gonna start giving it something to eat
yeah let's get some food uh what's your
thoughts on rome so far uh it's actually
awesome we watched like season one we
watched the whole season one yeah we
haven't watched season two yeah it's
great
yeah it's fantastic i liked it yeah um
yeah very historically accurate and it
matches up with everything that i've
read like you know what i mean through
my roman history you know [ __ ] gibbon
and everything you know if i can decline
and follow roman empire it all kind of
lines up and with a lot of and it just
makes a lot of sense you know it's how i
kind of imagined what had happened i
mean i really liked that they strove to
very modern
yeah like they kept it modern and they
kept it like cinematic
but it's still
really really historically accurate the
romans were a lot more modern than you
think i mean they were they were like
the people of today
i understand it a lot more now that i
see the way the u.s is going and just
the way their culture was is a lot of
parallels a lot of parallels ruling
classes are always the same
well humans only have like
you know we have like it's it's kind of
like bumper cars we have like these
little [ __ ] things around here you
can't really go outside yeah
you try to stay in power you try to make
money and you try to keep your [ __ ]
relevant and that's really what was
happening through most this move
okay
all right so
yeah man four hours and 16 minutes all
right we got to eat some food
i gotta sleep because i think i only got
three hours of sleep last night i'm
amazed i'm still awake and having a good
time uh but thank you everybody for
dropping by
really awesome i got through all the
cases
coherently hopefully so hopefully you
guys had a good time i had a good time
we will see you guys again on friday
evening for our sidetrack show which if
you are new here is just our
whatever you can just ask questions we
don't have a topic or anything like that
it's just a free-for-all so hopefully
you guys will
come and hang out with us again on
friday thanks for dropping by this
evening we will see you guys on friday
evening
good night